Yeah,
they'll click folks,
that's real time typing.
I don't fuck around to show us.
That's my,
that's my laptop for the 80th time show
has zero production value was even warn
you right now and this is the first one
you've ever listened to and you're like,
this is fucking Joe Rogan
shows like Tulio Professional.
You should edit it.
Stop now.
It's not going to get
any better from here.
This shows a mess and this episode is
brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com is
a website that allows you to use the
post office without actually having to go
to the post office.
You get to learn how to
send shit all out through your computer.
They send you a digital scale.
You get to measure everything printed
up on the computer and then put the
stickers on it and leave
it out for the post.
Man,
it's beautiful idea.
Whoever thought it up is a fucking genius.
It's the easiest way to have a business
and send shit to people without African.
Go without having to
go to the post office.
Wait in line.
Uh,
you know,
you don't want to do that and
they don't want you there either.
All right?
Figure that shit out
on your own bitch case.
Have a little laptop.
Get Yourself.
If you use a code word Jre,
get yourself a free digital scale that
you will only use for stamps.com you
fucks.
Don't be.
Don't be measuring your weed on
it and incriminating yourself.
People scrape and resin off euro.
You little scale there and
sending you to the jail.
If you go to stamps.com
use the code word j,
r e and you will get this special,
no risk trial,
no risk.
I love that.
That's what America loves.
No risk.
I want to be able just to shit,
get away with it.
Can you fix that?
Once they fixed bodies,
once they figured out how to fix bodies,
we're fucked.
It's everybody wants,
everybody wants no risk.
Right?
You saw the guy with the two,
the two arms,
the the guy in the marines or whatever.
It got blown up in Afghanistan
and they put prosthetics.
No,
they put other someone else's arms on it.
Oh my God.
Wow.
And it was on the Chive and
I've just remember like,
wow,
hey,
there really is a god.
He's going to kill us for this.
This is not that we are
playing a fine line here.
I mean,
it,
it was awesome.
I mean,
the guy looked,
he was,
it looked like he had lost
his arms and now had new arms.
I mean,
he was just to fill the look
on his face was just like,
that's incredible.
Wow.
And they didn't really move.
They just twisted a little bit.
It's still not no risk.
It's still a big fucking world.
Everybody wants zero risk.
They don't want you to stitch
somebody else's arms on,
oh no,
no,
no.
Don't,
don't,
don't take my arms off police.
Uh,
use a cohort jre and,
uh,
save yourself money and go stamps.com.
It's beautiful.
It's beautiful website.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a,
a website that allows you to do a lot
of illegal shit online without really
having to,
uh,
go to the,
um,
to the lawyers office and
spend a lot of money and wait,
do it on their time.
You can do it in your underwear.
You could do,
like,
you could make yourself an LLC.
You can incorporate for
only $99 while naked.
You could do whatever you want.
Like no one can tell
you what the fuck to do.
All right?
You could do it slowly.
You can take your time,
but you can do a lot of shit that you
otherwise would have to go to the lawyers
for.
And um,
you know,
save yourself a lot of
time and a lot of money.
Uh,
things like divorce.
You can get divorced,
you can get a will.
We all for just 69 bucks,
you can get divorced.
I don't know.
I might've made that up.
Can you get divorced?
Totally.
I think I totally made that up.
Zoom divorce that for me please.
Him and it's find out.
Are you in the middle of one?
Yes.
Okay.
Let's say,
isn't it funny when it
seems like when you're,
when you're not married,
it seems like,
Oh yeah,
legal doom does divorce starting at two
99 got damn Shay who divorced for 299
bucks.
You're listening.
It's going to be easy online.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
Do it online.
You know,
it's,
it's very unfortunate.
Divorce is very unfortunate,
but what's more unfortunate
is that marriage exists.
That's,
it's more than fortunate
with the more in French.
I for sure.
Don't get me wrong,
you absolutely,
women should be compensated when they
have children and I understand the idea of
alimony,
I get what's going on.
No one should suffer and yeah,
I get that totally 100% but at
what time do we just stop and go,
hey,
maybe it's not the best idea to just
get your finances all fucking tangled up
together where you want to break up
and you can't break up because all your
fucking credit cards and bank accounts
are together and your own the house
together or some crazy shit and you
absorb her student loans and now your
credit's fucked.
And she has to deal with the facts.
Your credit shit too because your car got
repossessed and together you're just a
fucking nightmare.
Then you have some,
some sort of lawyers that take
the extra third that they,
you know,
you,
we don't even end up with everything
with a lot less than you expected in the
first place.
Just paying other parties.
I've seen it.
I've seen it happen.
I'm,
I'm happily married parents.
I got lucky.
Perfect example.
Oh it happens with everybody.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
People are fucking crazy.
Me included.
We're all fucking crazy.
And the idea that we can get locked
into some nutty contract that says,
all right,
I'm not going anywhere.
You go anywhere.
No sign here.
Sometimes it works.
But that one third thing is
the thing that Phil Hartman,
you still say,
yeah and this is a guy whose
wife wound up killing him.
This is what he used to
always say is it's not half,
it's,
it's two thirds because the
lawyer gets a fucking third.
Like he was,
he was sweating it hard.
Did she,
did she do that?
Just killed him in his sleep.
But I mean,
but I'm saying with the divorced or,
or would they still know they
were still married but you know,
there's all sorts of rumors
as to why she was upset,
but she was obviously,
she was fucked up on some,
she was on Zoloft and cocaine apparently.
Allegedly.
It's quite that mix.
Even I think they got a
payment from Zoloft for that.
I think the family got money for it.
It's the whole thing is so fucking sad.
My point is it's not like
that would have changed it.
That's,
that's a crazy person and drugs
and all sorts of other things.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is that I just wish it
didn't have to be that people got crushed
like that.
I've watched dudes go down and
take a divorce hit that is like,
it just eats a year of your life
and they were miserable for a year.
Yeah.
It's so,
it's,
it's like any,
any like vicious separation like that.
It's hard enough just emotionally.
But then the tag into it,
the fucking battle that
people go through where they,
you know,
this fucking bitch,
she wants the house.
I'm not gonna fucking give it to you.
Ain't even like that house.
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
you see people get crazy.
Yeah.
What did he could've
just go his wife to zoom.
Kobe's wife took all three houses.
Did she?
I thought they got back
together in Newport coast.
That's what really,
I'm just saying,
it's just stuff that I've heard.
I don't like to talk about Colby.
Yeah.
Or his wife.
Fuck.
Do I know asshole.
Let me just get bullshit.
It's probably not him.
Coby got divorced on legal zoom.com.
Copy the shit.
Figured it out himself.
He's like,
just take,
um,
legal zoom.com,
uh,
can do a lot of shit though.
It's a suite.
A alternative to going to a lawyer and
spending a lot of money just isn't,
it's not really necessary.
And if you're in over your head,
they'll also provide you a contact
with an independent attorney.
So if you're in the middle
of it and you're like,
you know what,
I'm plugging panicking.
I think this is illegal.
I got to stop.
I'm with Ya.
I'm stupid too.
Okay.
If I had to go and do my own taxes,
who knows what the fuck I would have done?
Oh goodness.
It would be terrible.
It'd be a disaster.
I'm not designed for that shit.
You the code,
you use the codename Rogan and a in
the referral box and you can get more
savings.
It's a sweet,
sweet,
uh,
website.
If you're a in need of getting something
done and they just want to stress that
they're not a law firm.
They provide self help services
at your specific direction.
He use a codename Rogan.
We're also sponsored by on
at [inaudible] dot come.
That's o n n I t a human
optimization website.
We've got to get Ian Mccall,
some supplements.
Bitch.
I need some Alpha brain.
Can I get you some Alpha brain sign?
Have you ever tried it?
Ever take four during the show
and people go for what the fuck?
Yeah.
Horn take for don't be a pussy.
You're going to live forever.
Do you have any water for him?
Can we get him a lawn
or something like that?
You got a water stand
if you asked me to take,
I do understand,
but this is good for you.
I'm ready to take it.
We'll get you slides ready.
We'll have some delivered to you.
Um,
we also have a hemp force.
He would love that shit.
Hemp protein powder.
It's fucking delicious.
Mccoffee man bulletproof.
I got,
yeah,
I got it.
I read something saying that
that could be bad for you,
that I could possibly give
you a heart attacks and shit.
Like people are like,
look at it.
All the butter in the,
in the,
um,
in the coffee and they're like,
hey man,
this is probably not so good.
But I think they're probably
discounting the difference.
And I wonder if they are between,
uh,
the body's absorption of grass
fed butter versus regular butter.
If you never,
you don't know what the
fuck we're talking about.
There's a guy named Dave Asprey,
this like super eclectic genius dude who
collects all sorts of information about
human optimization.
He's a freak for this stuff.
And uh,
he runs the bulletproof exec.com and he
came up with this idea for bulletproof
coffee.
It's fucking genius.
It's grass fed butter,
MCT oil,
which is medium triglyceride oral.
And is that what it's called?
Is that what is called,
what the fuck was on a blank?
Mct Oil medium something,
whatever the fuck it is.
I don't remember what it call,
look,
it's good for you.
You know what it is?
Mct Oil is coconut oil,
but what they do is they spin it in
a centrifuge and by spinning it in a
centrifuge,
they can take out the,
the most nutritious aspects of it.
Medium chain triglycerides
is what they're called.
And um,
all that together mixed with the coffee.
Somehow or another,
it has like a slow release effect
because you have all the calories with it
because you have the calories of the
butter and you cowers of that like really
rich MCT oil and it's a slower release
sort of coffee thing so that you don't
have like,
like that massive crash.
If you drink like black coffee
and you have an empty stumper,
do you just go for it?
Four shots before every training session.
Do you force shots?
Holy Shit Man.
Have you ever tried doing
it with bulletproof coffee?
No,
I'm just,
I'm literally,
it was before,
like when I was sitting in Brazil,
I was on the Internet trying
to buy it off of your,
off of,
on it that you would,
I think you would enjoy it man.
This is what we have
some of it right here.
Do we have any shit that,
I drink it all the time.
If you want to try it,
I'll try.
I say try up here.
I don't have cooties.
Try some of them just
don't stick your tongue.
We sell.
We sell a lot of shit
like that though at on it.
We do sell bulletproof coffee,
but we tried to sell the most nutritious
and interesting things that we can find
like killer bee honey that is delicious.
It's delicious.
Stevia to no sugar.
Um,
Himalayan salt,
which is an incredibly rich in minerals.
If you don't know about the
benefits of natural salt.
If you thinking about any of these things,
whether it's the new tropics,
I always urge people to Google it.
It's,
it's a very interesting and fascinating
subject and the subject of supplements
themselves.
There's a lot of data,
you know,
from a lot of people that
seem to suggest that people,
it's more important to have diet and that,
uh,
your diet is really where you
get all your nutrients from,
which I agree that the
body absorbs nutrients most
certainly better from a rich
diet and a healthy diet,
but it's also really good to supplement.
That's don't be crazy.
They're both good.
Healthy vitamins are good,
healthy nutrients are good
and healthy amounts of,
uh,
of,
of vegetables,
green leafy vegetables.
That's shit so important.
Can't stress that enough.
I don't even sell vegetables,
but I always tell people,
you want to make your life better.
Eat more vegetables,
bitch.
You're eating fucking
cheeseburgers and empty food.
She eats perfect.
Yeah,
but no supplements.
And I'm trying to get
the responses by APS.
Hey,
as long as you eat perfect,
you don't need supplements.
Quite honestly,
I think there's certain supplements
that I would take regardless of my diet,
like shroom tech for uh,
for training or just things give
you extra energy or Melatonin.
If I wanted to sleep,
I would still take those things.
But I think that if you could eat like
just nothing but organic vegetables and
you're like all day and you,
you really ate healthy quantities of it,
you'd probably get enough nutrients.
You'll probably do if you really do.
I mean if you know the quantity,
yeah,
you'd have to eat massive quantities.
That's the thing.
Twice a day with me.
Yeah.
She's young though.
Look at her.
You're young and if I'm young,
people are vibrant,
they heal quicker.
My,
my daughter is three,
she's like Wolverine.
She gets a scratch.
It's gone by the end of the day.
They just suck up inside their body.
You know,
they're just growing that she
could eat cheeseburgers all day.
That's how young people
get away with shitty diets.
It's still amazing athletes.
You,
you give a hyper body and my daughter's
almost two and she literally,
I feel like she fall down a flight of
stairs and then five seconds later she's
doing jumping jacks and I'm like,
Oh wow,
nice.
Yeah,
totally.
They're going to have some supplements
one day that's going to be able to do
that.
You're going to be able to
rebound just like a little kid.
That's fucking for sure.
Common.
There's some crazy assholes right now,
just crack and all sorts of
things about the human body.
Back to Orange County.
Every man,
every 56 year old guys TRT that have is,
oh,
I had of his gills.
I saw one guy at out of this place
I eat all the time driving an Ra,
you know,
like totally had his head.
He thought he was on
point it at some point.
How sexy was he on a one to 10 for,
for a six year old man,
he was,
he was just about a 9.5 I saw a dude on
the beach that had to be 75 years old
and he was yoked.
Yeah.
And I should talk.
I'm 45 I'm 46 now.
I'm on TRT,
I'm on human growth hormone.
Let's take both of them.
So I take one like a little bit
less than one unit of growth a day.
And a,
I take a shot once a week of testosterone.
I used to do a cream,
but the creams,
like you gotta do it
every day and do a shot.
It's like once a week
and it's just a little,
it's just like too on a syringe,
whatever the fuck that is.
And it's not much for a week.
But if I don't,
I don't feel as good.
I try and get my dad on to
it because I know it'll,
it'll,
he's always fucking complaining about,
oh I'm 69 I'm old.
And like come on.
That's figured out.
He won't do it.
Cause he's an old surfer hippie,
but well it's becoming much more popular
and you see it all over the news,
testosterone replacement.
And people were like,
well what,
what's,
what about the negative benefits?
You know what?
The neck,
well,
there's a lot of negative benefits
on not using it that are undeniable,
like getting old.
All right?
So different effect on your body.
The reason why you're good old as your
body's not producing testosterone.
So you can be like proud and say,
well,
it's pseudo.
Just fucking go out in the
night like a cowboy or the,
you can just give you a
shot and then you're good.
Don't be stupid.
You know what do you want to not enjoy
your life as much when not have as much
energy.
Exactly.
You only have so long to live and
make those leaders those years better.
This is a message to buy on.
It is called get your shit together,
bitch.
That's the proposal.
Get your shit together,
bitch.
If you can get your
shit together at on it.
Some kettlebells,
battle ropes.
Just recover your life.
Get it together.
Drink some water fucker.
All right,
eat some good stuff.
Go to [inaudible] dot
com use the code name,
Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off
any and all supplements.
All right,
Ian Mccall's here we get official
experience.
Power
experience
in McCall.
Dude.
Thank you so much for doing this man.
Much requested by the underground forum.
Yes.
The UGC.
T T my,
my uh,
loyal followers.
Yeah.
What does that stand for?
The undergrad creepy top team
and,
and these,
these guys,
I've been there forever.
I've been on the underground
since 2002 or 2001 I think.
But they made this themselves,
they called themselves the UGC.
T t didn't make fun of other,
all the other top teams in the world
that that's why all the shirts have it on
it.
That's why we don't make money
off the shirts like that.
It's funny,
we just make it make enough to pay
for it and then we'd give away tons of
shirts.
I mean it's,
yeah,
that undergrounds kind
of mine if it's own,
yeah,
they could sway the opinion of,
of yeah,
the sport I think itself.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's funny how these things
sort of just sort of,
they just come out of nowhere on a forum
and then it becomes like a meme and
then it takes off like a,
like on the underground
it was always beep,
the homeowner detector like
Ted's and always have beef.
Like someone with some,
someone even this,
you could clearly see that some guys
with troll for beef but still like it's
very common if something happens,
some guy has his shirt off beep.
You know,
I had a long thread on the
underground for a while.
I don't know if you ever saw that.
What was it that the threat,
the threat of the,
the women that ever sleeping with no,
you had a thread with all the
women you were sleeping with.
I didn't go for it too.
Yeah.
That would seem like that
could get you in trouble.
I didn't know new today.
Oh No,
not yet.
But it was,
you know,
all the,
there was honestly it was a couple off
by a couple of hundred on there and it,
it was like a year long
and it just got ugly.
And then,
you know,
some people can be obviously complained
and threatened me and not make it on
there.
It's just there's stars over your parts.
And it was,
it was,
I am not that it probably feel like
it was a better idea at the time.
Yeah.
I thought it was,
I,
this was before I was in the UFC.
This is before I was,
it was a while ago.
And I just,
I just thought I was cool.
So that's really all,
I'm only good at the physical
things and everything else.
I suck cat fighting and,
and women.
I'm all right at,
well,
the underground has produced some of
the most epic threads I've ever seen on
message boards.
Did you ever read the one with the,
the,
the guy who's the
undefeated prison fighter?
Oh my God.
Christian.
I believe his name is Christian Darrow.
And uh,
he went to jail.
Super thick white dude.
Yeah,
it was a big,
he's quite some of the lots of tattoos.
Yeah.
And he,
he wound up having a,
a fight with this,
um,
fuck.
What is his name change?
Like,
God dammit,
I gotta,
I gotta look up this guy's name,
the kid who fought them because the kid
who fought them had some skills and just
beat the shit out of this guy.
But it was,
it was weird watching it.
It was like,
cause this guy even trained and he
might've not even have ever trained.
He might just be a crazy guy who lied.
And he talked himself into a being
the toughest man on the pizza,
having an MMA fight when he
really had no fucking business.
Do they fight in prison?
James Funaro that's his name.
No,
no,
no.
They fought in a gym.
I have a video of it.
There's a video of it online.
I don't even need to shit on the dude,
but,
but sorry,
he's sorry.
Yeah,
come on now.
I don't even know how
we got onto the subject.
I'm,
cause I,
I totally forgot.
Oh,
epic threats.
So that's how I found out about this
thread was from the underground.
There's,
did you ever read the grow?
Look tried to lick my pooper.
Jesus Christ.
The thread is like a
billion fucking pages long.
It's like crazy.
There's some threads that I have like
subscribed that I'll check in on every
couple of months.
You know,
like they have a podcast thread and uh,
you know,
every now and then I'll,
I'll jump in and they have
a thread about the podcasts.
I'll jump in and said,
just hire.
Those are your people.
They're nice people that look this,
this,
the amount of cuts in the world is,
is pretty high.
I love that word.
And when people are free to be
whoever they are anonymously,
you're going to get a lot of cons because
that's the root of all animosity is
cunty behavior.
I got trolled in Brazil and I would just
lost it on some guy cause he was just,
he just,
there's only one word he said,
but it just pissed me off.
It's constant,
but it's,
you know what it is that they're just
trying to have fun a lot of times by just
getting a rise out of you.
You've got to realize that and,
but it's also just,
it's not a natural way to communicate,
to not be in front of someone.
Like there's a lot of
things that you'd say,
an email he would never say in front.
Like,
that's my PSA.
I don't want to talk to you.
I'm just going to write your letters,
show you how to feel like bitch,
stop.
It will,
we'll just fucking letter.
Don't make me read.
Don't be a sissy.
Look at me and tell me what's going on.
Like you tell me what's the
problem and let's talk this out.
Because that's the best way to
communicate as looking at each other,
looking at each other and actually
saying what's on your mind.
You can't let things build up.
And yes,
she goes,
you're going to explode and end up,
you know,
doing something stupid.
Yeah.
And things can swing like left or right,
like good or bad,
depending on how you react to a moment
while you're in front of someone.
And a lot of times you would apologize,
you'd go,
look,
I shouldn't have said that.
Look,
I didn't mean it that way.
Or look,
let's,
this is where I'm coming from.
I don't,
you know,
when you see that,
when you're looking at each other,
yeah.
But you write it down in an email,
you can just be completely self
indulgent and just filled with nonsense.
And you think just because someone
wrote it down like it makes it real.
Oh,
respect feelings and this and that,
blah blah blah.
Shut up.
You fucking,
you've ever posted.
Just don't have the balls to
say clickety clickety clack.
Clickety could stop talk
stupid text messages.
He broke up with me over text messages.
Well that's horrible,
but if you are in a
nightmare relationship,
it's probably a good move.
That's true.
Like why be around them anymore than
you'd have to just go watch and just pull
cord twoish hey,
I,
you know,
I've been thinking I got to
go and you're kind of crazy.
Yeah.
Unfortunately we've all run into crazy
people and they've all run into us,
so there you go.
I attracted crazy for 99% of my life.
She did my friend,
you're,
you're old school man.
We talking about fucking understand that
you're talking about Chris Brennan and
Jeremy Williams and
that's next generation,
right?
All those guys.
Old School I started,
they'd like,
oh Roy Mcdonald's started
training MMA and like,
so did I.
That's,
that's what I'm [inaudible] man.
He was like a early pioneer Jujitsu guy.
He was like one of the first guys
around La to get really fucking good.
He was sick and I mean it just,
words were nasty.
Yeah.
He had a gang of setups to,
yeah,
a bunch of it and that,
that's that.
That was my,
that's what I took from him.
That was most of my game.
Yeah.
He's a tough dude,
man.
Really Good Jujitsu.
A lot of people slept on his Jujitsu
and then he went over to Japan,
but it was almost like on the
tail end of his competing,
you know,
when he was over in Japan.
Yeah.
He wasn't able to really
showcases how good he really was.
You have a bunch of epic
fights with Pat Miletich.
Um,
I know.
I mean,
didn't they have two fights?
They have two fights.
A fun,
was it UFC?
I remember he slept Joe Stevenson
and UFC when Joe was like 16.
Oh yeah.
Any held onto it.
The triangle for too long,
but that's the only kind of
knock out Antonio mucky too.
I was there.
That was bad.
Ooh,
that was the national check.
Nasty kick.
Chris Bannon was a bad mother fucker.
Yeah,
he's,
well,
he's doing Jujitsu in Dallas down,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
He's out living out in Dallas.
He,
you know,
he just wanted a change of scenery,
so he took it off and
that was good for him.
Then I left for him.
That's a beautiful thing about having,
you know,
reputation,
having a name.
Yeah.
You know,
in martial arts world like he does,
you could just start up a place
places and people would be like,
hey fucking Chris Bray and just
moved into town and that guys,
this is awesome man.
I mean,
he is a very,
very smart businessman.
Could you Jitsu Guy?
It's nasty fucking ears though.
Okay.
You [inaudible] son,
he's got some crazy
while lead Ishmael type.
He years.
He knows he's not the most
attractive man in the world,
but ABC,
his wife,
she's a beautiful creature.
I'm sure he's a tough dude.
I liked that guy too.
It's nice guy.
He was trained with Gerald Street.
Ben,
who's a buddy of mine.
Yeah,
I know Gerald.
Gerald.
A lot of dudes and just old school people.
Man.
How did you start finding,
um,
I liked fist fighting.
I mean that was me and my
boys thing in high school.
We all,
we wanted to fist fight
and it wasn't like,
and we,
you know,
we were in this stupid little gang
that the cops called this a gang,
but we were just a bunch of rich
white kids who like the fist fight.
And I mean we're talking
out of my friends,
let's say 20 of us,
18 of us trained and
10 of US had profiles.
We're talking to myself.
Shamed.
That was Oreo.
Robert Emerson,
Josh Smith.
Oh my God.
You guys all went out looking for fine.
Justin Levins.
Um,
she said,
imagine,
imagine.
Yeah,
we pulled the parties and
just push over a lantern.
I would,
because I was the smallest
one and all right,
go,
you know,
hit on someone's girlfriend or
to go steal cds or something.
And then some big jock would be like,
what's up?
And then of course I'm
not the guy to hide.
I want to jump in front
and talk some shit like,
Hey,
yeah,
and then they just kind of see it,
everybody behind me and kind of go,
ah,
no.
Okay.
Then all of a sudden I'm getting
what you want to be that guy.
I was,
I dunno,
I had something to prove.
I was tiny and I liked fist fighting.
It wasn't like I wanted to,
you know,
drop somebody.
You weren't even thinking that you were
like disturbing people's private lives
and interfere.
No,
I understood that I was,
that was a dick when I was a kid.
I was a horrible child.
I literally was.
I spent most of my life being a
horrible person doing a whore.
What made you realize that you were,
that was a bad person.
20 some odd years of doing bad stuff and
then just just trying to pull out of it
and constantly falling back into it.
Trying to pull out of it,
falling back into it.
And now I have a kid and now I have a,
for once in my life I have a positive
female influence as far as dating goes.
And I mean it,
it helps me,
you know,
I don't,
I've literally done everything possible
I think a fucking psychopath would want
to do,
but I've done just about everything,
you know,
I can't really think of besides,
um,
you know,
having a man to enter me.
I've done it as young.
Yeah.
You know,
you did.
But it,
I'm just saying it and I've just,
you know,
now I've got a kid in a career and I'm
just trying to settle down and be a good
boy.
Yeah.
You're,
it's kind of a wild past for a dude who's
like a top level professional athlete.
If people listening to
this on the podcast,
you know,
without getting to know you better,
I'm like,
what the fuck is this guy?
I was one of the best
flyweights on the planet.
I mean I'm the best
look dudes may on any given night in,
in the world of high level
of mixed martial arts,
anybody can beat anybody.
And I thought you'd be Dj in the
first fight and then you guys,
well this is I think,
and correct me if you disagree.
I think that there has to be,
uh,
an
element of the fight where when one
person is like doing something like really
dominant to the other person
that's got to count for more.
Yeah.
Like when a guy's got a guy's back,
like he had his backend pounded on them,
that's got to count for more
than just winning around all,
you know,
barely.
Like if a guy wins around
with like strikes and 10
more strikes be more strikes
or the next guy gets into
a really good position,
it does significant damage.
That's not,
it's not the same point.
It's a different,
it doesn't make sense to
me the way things are now.
I think that,
um,
you do know doc Hamilton's I'd go,
yeah.
Do you like that idea?
It's a half point idea.
Yeah.
I like that.
Did actually,
it makes,
I mean it just,
it,
it sounds nice,
but we have people that
have no business judging,
judging flies and then
like literally let's,
let's say if I would have won that fight,
my,
I wouldn't have gone into some just
horrible spiral out of control for the,
the next year of my UFC career,
right after written my very first fight,
you know,
back to just being stupid and
doing horrible things to myself.
Do you think you would have done that?
No.
That's what I did.
How you did after that.
That's why I DJ kicked
my ass a second time.
That's why Joe,
I didn't do anything
to Joe when I could've,
I mean I should have done a lot better.
Both guys said I could have
finished them and then I just,
I just,
I had to just a mental bad marriage.
It's all,
it was,
I don't want to get into it
right now just in a bad place.
It was a really bad place and it wasn't
performing and we are all top level
athletes,
but I know I'm better than these guys.
It's just they were better that night.
They're better performers
at at this point in time.
Mentally it's what it comes down to
is the mental aspect and you know,
I'll get back now I'm happy and
then I'm finally in a good place.
I think against Joe,
I was getting there,
but I wasn't quite there yet.
I mean physically I'll always be there,
you know?
But it's just for me mentally,
even this last fight I did great,
you know?
But I think I still have steps to
get back to where I know I can't be,
like when it became world champion,
it was just,
it just,
it was just better.
You know?
I was just training harder and
longer and faster and everything.
I mean,
now I'm technically better I think,
but it's just getting my
head betters is still,
it's still a process,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm almost there,
I guess.
So you,
you feel like you're a work in progress?
Of course.
Always.
Yeah.
Do you feel like all this
shit that's happened to you?
All this craziness in your life,
the mistakes that you've made,
like in some ways surviving
as many mistakes as you have,
like really creates a very fascinating
person because the type of person has as
many experiences as you.
It's a very,
uh,
it's a,
it's a magnetic thing to be around cause
most people haven't had as many crazy
fucked up life experiences and have been,
you know,
professional cage
fighters at the same time.
I,
and now I'm trying to do now
becoming a better person for once.
I'm trying to be that better person.
I'm trying to just show people like,
this is what,
this is what I've done.
I'm a walking example of what not to do
because most likely you're not going to
get back to where I am.
You know,
almost like a,
you're either going to
become just a human being
or you're going to die,
you know,
like calm down.
Yeah.
Or you're going to die.
And then you figure it out on
your own or you're on a bad path.
And I think that for some reason I'm,
I'm able to,
I,
I've been able to do to do that and make,
get back to greatness and try and do
something that no one really ever gets to
do.
And that's fight in the octagon.
You know,
they're very few percentage of people
in the world that actually kept,
will ever be able to do this.
Right.
So especially at your weight class man.
Yeah.
You know,
that's really fucking technical way class.
That Dj,
he keeps getting better to everywhere.
Every time he fights.
Man.
His uh,
last fight with Morocco was incredible.
Yeah.
He's so good at like changing
where the fight takes place,
whether it's taking you down,
kicking you and you think
he's going to punch you,
punch you,
is going to kick you.
And he's,
he is ever evolving.
I make fun of him a lot.
I do because he can't help because yeah,
he,
yeah,
exactly.
I got a,
I got a chip on my shoulder because I
thought I beat him and then he beat me up
and plus I think he's a nerd.
But,
um,
but he's just such a nice guy.
But something wrong with being a nerd.
No,
nothing,
aren't being retired.
I just can't make fun of him
because he beat me up on time.
Right.
Just let me do that.
But now he,
he's the guy is,
he's at first people gave him so much
guff because he just wasn't performing.
But now he's getting better.
He's getting to the point where he,
the strides he's making are making
it actually exciting and they,
the adoring public is actually,
uh,
not being such a Douche bags that are
learning the sport and realizing that
that's,
that's art right there.
You know,
he's,
he's painting a fucking masterpiece,
you know,
especially compared to these big guys.
Not to say that anything against big guys,
but we're doing a lot more than they are.
Yeah.
It's,
well,
it's definitely a different game.
The,
the pace is faster.
It's more technical.
There's very little room for error.
Yeah.
You know,
like he called Moraga and that gear team,
there was no room.
It's just like,
just snatched it up.
You know?
It's,
uh,
it's really kind of an interesting
difference between watching the,
the smallest way class and watching the
largest way cross the room for error.
It's incredible.
The guy becomes a lot bigger.
Oh my God.
I mean if we've never seen a
heavyweight that moves like,
like a flyweight says it.
He says it doesn't exist.
No,
it's a completely different
experience watching the,
the lighter weight classes.
It's like you guys are like hummingbirds,
you're like a moving
at such a faster pace.
You know,
it's,
it's hard.
I mean even just to fight at that pace.
I mean you gotta be on point
because if you're one step behind,
I mean it's just a constant pop,
pop,
pop.
Just like each kid got caught by
my Raga big time that fourth round.
It's a perfect example of that.
I mean Dj was not getting hit by anything.
He was just moving like a ghost.
He was in and out.
And when you thought he was coming in,
he was coming out.
I mean,
it was a beautiful performance.
And then boom,
he hits hard.
He hits hard,
you know,
he gets hard.
But even the point is like [inaudible]
anytime it can come anytime a big one
point clip you,
yeah.
That's the craziest thing about the sport,
isn't it?
Yeah.
This is really nothing like that.
It's so rare and boxing for things to
around out of nowhere with one shot.
It doesn't happen that often.
Like later,
you know,
in a fight when you see it in,
in MMA,
that it can happen at any
moment with those little gloves.
Yeah.
It just slips right through.
The,
I of people really don't
get is that defense.
Even having your defense has to be
perfect because those little gloves fit
through the smallest holes and they make,
they make,
they make those holes bigger.
It's not just like a boxing glove where
it's a blunt object that's just going to
expand and on impact,
you know?
Yeah.
There's much less give
the slide through things,
especially in they get all greased up,
sweaty up like the Todd Duffy,
Mike Russell fight is a
fight that I always point to.
If you never saw that fight,
if you've never seen that fight is one
of like it's a historical MMA fight.
Yeah.
They played that for young fighters.
They go,
this is what can happen.
This guy motherfucker looks like superman,
three rounds,
three rounds of horrific beating.
Broke his arm.
Yeah.
Russell had a broken arm and then at an
with no hint whatsoever that that it was
going to take place before this.
It wasn't like he had tagged
them a couple of times.
It looked like he had them
stagger it a few times.
Like he's coming back,
he's getting just destroyed and plus
it's Duffy is a physical specimen.
That guy's huge and and Mike not so much.
Yeah.
Mike is,
looks like what he has is a Chicago cop.
Excises a tough fucking guy.
No doubt about it.
It's super tough.
Fucking guy.
But that punch was like
one of the quickest turn.
It was out of nowhere.
Yeah.
It turned the whole fight or out bang.
He had him hurting.
Boom.
He was out like what the hell?
Like how is that even possible?
I mean,
especially at that weight,
you know when you have,
when you have two guys that are 250
pounds hitting each other that hard.
I mean that,
that is frightening.
And I see where the heavy weight,
you know,
my roommate,
she ended up Rosario to see him move and
he's fast and it hasn't been able to,
you know,
to really show how good he really is.
But man,
that guy can move and it's,
I mean it is,
it scares the crap out of him.
He can hold pads for me.
That's how fast he is.
Wow.
And I mean I,
I'll go for 30 minutes
straight by la La la La la.
Yeah.
He moves really well and he's set that
weight of heavyweight where there's like
a point of diminishing returns.
A lot of people believe
there's an argument about it.
It was,
and that argument is about like two 40
that are like anything bigger than are
like Cain Velasquez.
You get tired too easy.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
but you know,
then,
but then for a while there,
it was like,
people thought it was like when Brock
Lesnar like first burst on the scene,
people are like,
Oh shit,
you got to get way bigger mat.
That's what frank wait,
Geiger,
Shane Carwyn got way bigger.
Those dudes got way bigger.
They're like,
fuck that dude is,
that's your game.
If you're game is,
you know,
Tuck your face in between your
shoulders and plow forward.
If that's your game and
you better be built,
like that guy shines.
Just hulk smash people.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
It doesn't work out so well.
Yeah.
It's when you watch a fight
like Carwyn versus less than,
which is at an all time classic fight.
But you see how quick Carlin gasses out,
like to the point where he's dead.
It's like one round within run.
It's like you,
well,
first of all,
I think he said it was also that he
was so fired up so much adrenaline.
He couldn't believe.
He thought he was winning and
thought the fight was over.
I thought it was gonna
win the fight right there.
And he was beating on him for a long time.
So I mean,
that's,
that's going to take,
not just 10 seconds.
If I thought I wanted,
it was
a couple of minutes of,
I thought I won.
And he was sprinting.
You mean it was two minutes of sprinting
and literally after it was over,
Brock survived that.
He was done.
Like he couldn't even
get up out of his stool.
I was like his whole body
like completely shut down.
It was crazy to watch.
Yeah,
but you will watch a body like that.
That's when you go,
okay.
How big is too big?
Yeah.
Cause that might be too big.
Like you got to,
someone's got to figure this out.
Like scientifically.
Yeah.
We got to figure it out.
What it's,
I don't know anything about crossfit,
but my,
my roommate and he runs RV sport for
Ruca and he went to go sponsors guys and
talked to some people and watch it.
And I always thought,
Gosh,
you guys are douchebags.
I don't know.
I just always hear him
yelling and screaming.
I hate her.
He's like,
no,
did,
they're really positive.
They're cool guys.
And the,
the,
uh,
apparently like the perfect way for them.
It's like one 85,
200 pounds for what they do.
And that's,
which is,
I don't even really know what they
should do a bit way it was Christ.
It's just stupid way.
I mean,
I don't see stupid like dumb.
I mean like,
like Holy Shit.
I've seen this,
a little guy who was like 165 pounds
and he was doing cleans with a,
I think it was cleans with
120 pound kettle bell.
He was still,
he was not a big guy and he's doing this
clean press over and over again with
this.
It was more than a
hundred pound kettle bell.
It's ridiculous.
Whatever the fuck it was.
Yeah.
And he was doing it for Reps.
I was like,
this is incredible.
I can,
we've got a 200,
we have multiple stones.
We got 125 pounds stone at uh,
at my strength conditioning place.
God Damn,
you know,
roll it up on my legs and I can pop pop.
But it's just a stone.
It's just,
that's something,
that's where I get my suplexes from.
But I would think it probably
would help you a lot,
man.
But I mean I can,
I can get out the two.
I think it's two 52 40 I can get
that up and do it maybe five times.
But I mean it's,
it's,
it's getting it out onto
your lap is the hardest part.
I can explode probably
400 pounds off my hips.
I mean that's a professional athlete.
Isn't it fascinating to see like how much
things have changed as far as like the
way they train athletes,
some of the ideas behind it.
If you go back,
like if you're a student of the game and
you go back just like 2030 years like
these like Angela Dundee's until
fighters and not lift weights.
Yeah.
They said tell him that a lot.
A lot of weights and it
was going to slow you down.
Yeah,
they,
they couldn't,
they just didn't,
they just,
they didn't know.
They didn't understand.
They didn't know.
Well it does slow you down in that if
you lift weights and you're sore the next
day you're going to be slower.
And then the coach was like,
God slowing you down.
But then Mackey shields stone comes along
and trains Evander Holyfield to go up
to heavyweight.
Yeah.
And all of a sudden heavy.
He's like a real heavyweight.
He was like two oh five
or something like that.
Like not too big,
but he was big enough and he was,
he got fucking
Oh,
oh my God.
Was He Jack 40 holy film.
How old was he when he
went up to heavyweight?
He started out as a cruiserweight.
Right.
Cause he fought Dwight Kawai.
That was like a one 95 right.
That's cruiserweight.
And then when he went up to heavyweight,
was it Mackey shields don't work with him?
It did.
Right.
Cause he worked with,
he worked with Spinks,
right?
Yeah.
He worked with Michael Spinks when he
was bulking Spinks up to be a heavyweight
to fight Tyson and Larry Holmes.
That was when he burst into the scene.
He was like one of those first
guys that was [inaudible].
They were realizing back in the day,
like we got to do things a little
different here we can just do curls,
which yes,
that guys in San Clemente and I,
and I've never had a run in with him,
but all my friends have
and all my coaches,
I did,
he ate.
Apparently he's just very set
in his ways I guess we'll say.
But I'm in that he was an originator of,
of so much crazy stuff.
And we look at the sun.
I mean that didn't turn
out like it should have.
Well I was under a tremendous of,
for people who don't know the whole store,
I don't know his son's name
cause I'm not a football fan.
What does this on the name?
Todd Todd.
Todd Todd and uh,
there's a good documentary on it and
Marinovich is like a cow racy strength and
fitness guy.
And he's the guy who got Bj Penn
in the best shape of his life ever.
When Bj fan fought Diego Sanchez
and when he fought Sean Penn,
I think those are the two times Sean Penn,
Sean to Shirk Jesus Christ.
Right after I said it.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's right.
He Flood Sean Sherk and Diego and I
think that Bj was like one of the best
fighters I've ever seen in my life.
Elite beach.
That's my,
the guy I've always looked up
to the most because that was,
he was old school and people fee.
He made Joe Stevens and cry.
He beat a man up so bad that he
was crying in the fucking corner.
Bj Penn was a motherfucker
man for a long time.
That's the kind of fighter I want to,
I want to get myself too,
because when people need to fear people,
you know,
I want to be fucking
feared because then people,
you know,
you beat him up and
they cry in the corner.
That,
that,
that's,
that makes me feel,
well,
I mean,
look,
what do you,
I mean that's,
that's the path you're on.
You're on the path to excellence
and the people fear the scariest,
most excellent fighters.
I mean,
there's no really disguising what's
the sports about exactly that.
Sports about victory.
It's about beating the other man.
It's about imposing your martial arts
skills and you really can't get great at
that and not be scary as fuck.
It's part of the program.
What brings out the most
primal urges in us that,
that I,
you know,
I want to kill something and
eat it with my bare hands.
I wanted to like,
you know,
I want to just be that,
King Stink.
I want to be the,
the head monkey,
you know,
I do.
I want to be able to do that.
Do you think you have that
extra bad from growing up small?
Oh yeah.
Cause I always wanted to prove myself.
My parents,
especially my mom.
I think my dad really cared,
but um,
cause he always knew I was,
you know,
I was,
I could do it.
My mom wanted to show everybody else
that I do every single sport and you're
good at it.
Oh Wow.
Cause I was,
I was good at everything.
I mean,
how much did you weigh when
you were in high school?
I wrestled one oh three
one oh three one 12 one 19.
But I got into high school
at a hundred pounds.
Wow.
But then again,
I've been doing Kung Fu San Suu my whole
life by the black belt in that which
you don't compete.
It's,
I learned how to and I was the big
league and was my scent might my seafood.
He was,
he just,
I was his protege and he's like,
I'm going to teach you things
that I don't teach other kids.
Okay.
You have this red zone around you.
If they would get in within arm's length,
w there a problem,
you need to hit them.
I got,
you know,
in a threatening manner and I got,
I would punch kids in the throat,
elbows,
you know,
I would love that.
I learned arm,
arm,
armbar kind of stuff back then,
kick jump kits in the face or the groin.
Like I got kicked out of all
of the best private schools.
So it was always people fucking with
you and you defending yourself against
assholes or it was you
being an asshole sometimes.
A lot of the time it started out as
me wanting to beat up the bullies.
That's how it turned into me being like,
you know what?
Fuck those guys.
I want to beat up every bully I see.
And I did it,
you know,
like I got kicked out of what my high
school one year for beating up some Cholo
for picking on my friends,
uh,
um,
mentally handicapped cousin with down
syndrome and I might beat the shit out of
it.
What kind of a world is it where you
get in trouble for that and well,
what happened was I beat him up
and then I felt someone grab me.
So of course I thought it wasn't one of
his friends and I turned around and like
swept the person on the ground
and it was one of the proctors,
one of the female proctors and then,
oh and I ran away.
He swept her and it's just,
you know,
just kind of to kids style,
sweep the leg.
Yeah.
It just turned around and like,
cause I,
she grabbed me from,
you know,
one side and I put my,
my arm out on the chest and just swept
the leg and just so dangerous to grab
someone in the middle of a fight.
And she probably wouldn't even think
that because it's probably not a violent
person.
Yeah,
she was super nice.
She,
she just,
I had to be pulled out of school.
My coach pulled me out of school three
out of the four years from freshman,
sophomore,
junior year because after
wrestling season I would just la.
So you needed the discipline of
wrestling to keep you in check?
Oh yeah.
That's the only that,
that,
that I owe my life to have to have
a small group of people and Reza,
Betty,
my old wrestling coach
was one of them that,
I mean that guy saved me.
Yeah,
isn't it?
It's an amazing thing.
How many people have been saved by the
diversity there comes from something like
that,
whether it's boxing or MMA or wrestling or
she gets,
for me it was taekwondo.
You just knew I needed something.
I needed some,
some form of discipline,
something that can,
I can like enjoy and I can attack it
and I can get really good at it and it
gives me a calmness because most boys,
like people who are not
boys don't remember it.
I guess when they get older or they forget
because they have problems with their
own,
they don't want to deal with it.
When you're like 15,
16 years old,
you're fucking crazy.
You're body's bouncing around,
hormones are flying through your system,
you're walking around,
your dick is hard all the time and you're
crazy and you're basically almost a
man.
Yeah.
And you're like thinking,
I'm kind of fucking almost a mat.
And that was how beating up
guys that were in college.
So I was,
I was,
you know,
I thought I was fucking super cool.
I was out stealing my dad's super as which
we built in a built supra or quarter.
There were cars and they would steal
those and he knows or whatever.
Um,
you know,
I was living,
living in South Orange County and just,
just getting away with whatever I wanted.
My parents,
I was too fast for them,
so I,
you know,
that,
and they were going
through their own stuff,
you know?
So of course,
you know,
like I just was off on my own,
just being crazy.
And,
I mean,
I started smoking weed
when I was eight years old.
That's a good to know.
Start.
So he was,
yeah,
it's not sex.
That's an eight.
Sounded good.
And it wasn't like it was a bad influence,
you know,
it was just,
it just happened.
And I mean crazy.
Yeah,
you're smoking weed.
God Damn,
that's so crazy.
They go to school and kids,
you'd be like,
Oh my God,
my dad let me have a sip of beer.
And I was like,
I drink a 40 and took four
foot bong rips all weekend.
God,
how old were you?
Uh,
you know,
going through like middle
school or whatever,
and kids just didn't understand.
I mean,
that'd be a private school and I wouldn't,
I never,
you know,
I was always,
you don't,
you don't talk about stuff like that,
especially,
you don't wanna get in trouble.
Right.
So of course I always kept my mouth shut,
but you know,
I was,
I was a degenerate at a young age,
you know,
it was just,
it was just in me to just,
I want it to be the bad guy.
I wanted to have that fun.
And where,
where do you think that came from
then when you think about it now,
when you're trying to be a calm
guy and you have a kid and your,
your triggers on track and you're like,
you reflect back to
like your wildest shit.
Like what makes you think had,
you know,
I had a great upbringing.
Literally,
I did this all to myself,
right?
My parents are awesome people.
The sure they went through a divorce,
but that,
that doesn't turn.
Let me stop you right there because I
think it's really difficult to understand
or underestimate the negative impact
of being bullied can have on a person.
Yeah.
It's,
it's huge.
You know,
and people say like that it's,
it's not like being molested or abused.
And I say bullshit.
I say it's probably pretty
close to a lot of guys.
Yeah.
For,
I mean,
it's not,
it's might not be the physical humiliation
of someone's forcing you to have sex,
but the,
the physical intimidation
aspect of it is terrifying.
Can,
it changes your perception of reality
when you're around that person.
The,
there's constant danger.
You're going to get swatted,
you're going to get pushed,
you're going to get compromised.
It's a terrible,
terrible thing.
And it can fuck with people and it can
turn people into depressed people who
want to kill themselves because of that,
because they can't take
the pain anymore and it,
and people don't realize
it when they're doing it.
I don't think,
I think,
you know,
they're probably bullied
at home or you know,
someone bullied them and you know,
they're insecure or they're
beaten or whatever the fuck it is.
So they go to school and they just
conked out on some little kid.
Yeah.
But man,
I've,
I've seen it have devastating impacts.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
you just see it in high
school and then what I would,
I always did it in high school was I
would pick on the bullies or pick on the
cool kids because,
because you know,
the,
the class president types,
I would,
I would just like,
I just like talking shit to,
it was just,
it was fun.
Yeah.
I had always had a big mouth.
I got pretty lucky with
not getting the fuck beat.
Not,
I mean high school.
Yeah,
we'll see.
The only time I ever got really beat up
I think in street fights was cause I was
at picking my battles.
I know,
you know,
I know I can beat that guy up.
I'm just small,
you know.
But like I,
I would always try and test it,
but I got,
you know,
we used to go as groups,
me and my friends,
we would go beat up a bunch of
skinheads in the next neighboring town.
Like all the time I got
booted and you know,
booty boy,
those guys twice at del Taco
and once at a house party.
But you know,
it's,
you get beat up.
I get beat up on national TV
now and it's not that bad.
But I mean when you're getting beat up,
I mean,
especially as a kid getting beat up by,
by a bully,
by someone in front of
other people and that,
that like Chamilian.
It's horrible.
And that's why I would always try
and stick up for the kids getting,
getting bullied.
And it's also at a time in your life
when you're the most vulnerable.
It's really hard for you to really
understand what's going on in life.
And you know,
people make a lot of terrible
mistakes at those young ages.
And I think one of them
is actually being a bully.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I think that,
that,
that kind of Karma like
pushing out in that direction.
You're a 10 year old asshole.
Yeah.
I want to punch you in the face.
You know,
I started getting into martial
arts just because I was scared.
I just wanted people to be scared of me.
I don't want to,
I didn't want to do anything.
Like I wasn't,
I didn't want to start fights.
I just wanted everybody
to be scared of me.
I want it.
I want it to be Wolverine.
So
you've got the look.
Yes.
It's,
um,
it's a weird thing,
but the,
the interesting aspect of it is that
I'm a huge MMA fan and I don't think you
have MMA if you don't have bullies.
It's true.
It's really kind of fucked up.
But one of the things,
I mean,
it's not everybody,
but God damn,
a lot of them have been bullied.
Like,
I don't know if Jon
Jones had been bullied,
but I do know that Jon Jones has a bigger
brother and they used to go at it in
the house all the time.
So like that's,
it's not bullied because
it's not dangerous.
I mean it's like your brother,
but it's still like you
got to fight all the time.
Oh my brother used to
beat the crap out of me.
My oldest brother Tom,
he was kind of a Dick.
He was,
he was,
he was a bully.
But he's,
you know,
he's like 15 years older than me.
My brother Brad,
who fought professionally
before there was anything,
you know,
like I told you,
you funny fan and stuff and he was five
[inaudible] five and one or six in one.
You said we trained a 10th planet chain
with Eddie at 10th and you attend a,
but we know we were at
next generation and our,
when we would get mad at each other,
I mean we can be at the
gym and I'm sure he,
you know,
he never probably really let me have it,
but he used to beat the
crap out of me and that was,
I was 15 getting beat up by grown men by
the CRISPR and the Adam Lindsay and my
brother Jeremy.
It's sucked,
man.
But that fucking sucks.
Yeah,
it was horrible.
It was.
It was,
but it made me the fighter I am now.
Yeah.
But that's almost,
I mean,
I mean not encouraging bullies in
any stretch of the imagination,
but George St Pierre was
bullied the greatest fighter
of all time because one of
the all time greats.
But yeah,
by far,
I don't know about Anderson Silva,
but I would like to know,
I want to wonder whether
the voice like that,
I mean,
he for sure was in a
dangerous area growing up.
Yeah.
It seems like those days,
like a,
it's funny,
just like watching those
old fights and those guys,
shoot,
the box guys would all
come in like a gang.
Yeah,
they were the mother fuckers.
I mean fighting in like backyards.
Oh you want some grass?
The concrete,
the STUCCO wall.
Those were tiny Peter.
It's like when you go,
like you look at the,
the early days of pride and you see like
Vandelay and Shogun and Ninja like God
damn,
they were the scariest motherfuckers.
Wild Ass Brazilian dude's
trying to step on your face.
Oh yeah,
like trying to Japan.
There's not a drug test to be had.
They were pretty open about it back then.
I mean I've,
I've heard things from there.
They were like,
hey guys,
guess what?
We don't,
we don't test for steroids.
Yeah,
well they tell you to get on them too.
I had a friend who he was a hunter and
70 and they wanted him to go to one 85
we'd give you a steroids
that gives you say what?
They were just like ready to go.
They were just going gangster.
I mean they,
you know,
and a lot of ways I was really happy
that pride existed and yet it was as wild
as it was because they put together
shit that no one would ever sanction.
Like a Toro versus Bob Sapp.
Yeah.
When Bob Sapp was three 70 plus like
people don't realize that that's real.
He was up 370 fucking pounds
choice like bringing in these,
just these oddities out.
You're just like,
what was the big fat
black guy from Brazil?
I'm Zulu Ino or whatever.
Yeah.
I mean he could fake it fight,
but he was,
it just,
they just see these,
well he was Zulu son.
They see the Japanese
see things differently.
They just see as entertainment.
You know,
they see a black guy and they're like,
oh hey,
he's got to be entertaining.
That's why he's here.
You know,
like you get Quentin,
like I love him over there.
Well Clinton also had some fights.
I'm just saying they just,
the Japanese,
they have the niche that they like
and they just make it the weirdest,
craziest shit they can.
Anybody who complains about
Quentin Rampage Jackson,
you are not an MMA fan.
If you complain about rampage,
I don't care where he's at now.
I don't care.
Whatever.
Stop,
go back and watch those pride fights
and shut the fuck up because bad ass,
his fight with Kevin
Randleman incredible fight.
His fight with a Rona Ms.
One of the highlight all
times slams in the history of
MMA.
That's when he was with my coach.
Oh,
Yama.
Ah,
yeah,
yeah.
Rampage was a beast,
man.
Oh Yamaha.
Him thrown more leg kicks.
Yet I'm doing a lot of different
things that he's doing it.
He became like a real
power puncher after awhile,
just,
you know,
I'm,
look,
rampage can still knock
out anyone in the world.
If he catches anyone in the world,
they're fucks.
We're going asleep.
He has answered hammers.
That right hook that he
had chocolate dealt with.
I'll never forget that day hunch.
He just,
he ducked chuck through a laughed and
he came over the top of the right,
but whatever it was,
I think Chuck was pawn with his jab.
May Be he's trying to set up the right,
whatever it was.
Rampage hit him with either,
I think it was a counter right hook.
They the end of they were circling,
I can see the camera.
You're now bear barely remember
Chuck's one of my best friends.
So that's the [inaudible] membrane,
you know,
but see I think there are circling left
and then of course you know [inaudible]
something.
He threw that right and just boom.
That was rampage had that ridiculous
one punch power that Vandelay fights.
Another example.
God Damn he uncorked that
left took on the button.
You're going nine night.
Nobody had ever done,
I mean cro,
cop t he hit him a gang at
times for 40 flatline dumb.
He was a lighting Vandelay up in that
fight because the first time they fought
it was an incredible fight.
But Cro cop just really
wasn't good on the ground yet.
He has takedown defense.
Was He there?
Very little.
And they had a strange rules fight.
Whereas like you can only see on
the ground for a little bit of time.
There's like a minute or something.
Just like short periods,
some short period.
So Cro cop would just
lock them up in a guard.
Yeah.
And try to hang on.
I don't know what rules they had.
It was a weird rule thing.
It was private.
But then in the second fight cro cop
had had a few MMA fights and he got his
timing down and that was
when cro cop was cro cop man.
He was Scott.
That was a scary man.
I mean he is again,
one of the scariest tools to ever exist
ever an MMA that he knocked out multiple
people with.
And you did.
The thing about cro cop
is I feel like UFC fans,
again don't appreciate the
majesty of that was cro.
Cop now has prime,
we got 'em after a long career,
a hard career against fatal
or and against Josh Barnett.
I mean he fought some battles.
So when by the time we
got them in the UFC,
he had been in quite a few like real,
real world.
And think of all of the heavyweight
kickboxing fights it yet.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
He fought a lot of k one
fights against the top guys.
Yeah,
high level,
high level guys that Mark Hunt fight
so I can elastic one man classic.
They had some wars in in,
in k one man.
People had,
I mean he was a in the mix with some
of the best fighters in the world over
there.
He got,
you know,
you've got the [inaudible] are small,
small Allister,
um,
Peter a year.
It's,
you know,
the,
the Tyrone Spong is like the,
the Dutch group of kickboxers.
The heavyweights are,
I mean,
and these guys have like a
hundred heavyweight fights,
200 heavyweight fights.
I mean this is insane.
I mean someone lie sides.
Okay.
You have 200 Thai fights in Thailand.
It's still sits still pretty gnarly.
It's,
it's more than not,
it's crazy,
but I mean double the size and
almost the same amount of flights.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's just,
that's completely insane.
It's incredible.
I mean dude had 29
kickboxing fights on record,
on record and then 41 MMA fights.
God Damn.
Yeah.
He had some great
fucking k one fights too,
man.
Really Fun King.
He see,
he was one of the best guys to come over
even though he wasn't one of the best k
one guys.
He was like just below the,
the elite of the elite.
Like it wasn't just below
like the Grand Prix winners.
Exactly.
Before he did win a ground pre recently.
Yeah,
right.
There was in a,
it was the big European men or something,
something like that.
I'll,
I'll find out and give him
the credit he deserves.
But um,
when he,
uh,
when he came over he was,
he had the one thing that a lot of
people didn't have ridiculous speed and
explosion and he had like,
I think he had a karate background,
right?
Correct.
When we first started it,
you started like,
I'm sure that was a long,
long time ago.
John Claude van Damme movies or something
like that and learn how to kick that
way and then got
something crazy like that,
I believe.
I believe that that's
like how it got started.
I think he liked,
it was a John Claude van Damme
fan and I know karate from that,
but his fucking kicks are so unusual.
Like angle.
Oh speed.
The speed is ridiculous
and he's got horse legs.
Like those things are huge.
So of course those,
those,
those kicking you in the face
is going to not feel good.
And he again,
I mean it was like he had that weight.
It was like,
you know,
to 30th,
two 28 he said yeah to 28 is what he
like the average that he weighed when he
was in his prime and it was just scary
fast when knocked out Bob Sapp Zap was
three fucking 70 and Mirko Cro cop.
No he right handed or left handed.
I'm a straight left to the eye socket.
Remember on broke.
Is that okay?
And then yeah,
he broke his eye socket bone.
I think he kicked him before that.
Okay.
I mean I remember I kick to the body,
see if you can find that,
see if he could find a
cro cop versus Bob Sapp.
Cause that was one of
cro cop's best fights.
And he was a,
it was a kickboxing fight too.
You know,
that was back when this was a guy
Bob Sapp who had beaten Ernesto,
who's too most people think was the
greatest ever or one of the top 10 guys
ever.
For sure.
Yeah.
I shouldn't say the greatest ever,
like even Dutch guy say,
but it's kind of between him when he's
in his prime or like a rob came in or uh,
or of course Ramon Dekkers deckers gets
the most credit because he fought the
lights.
Guys,
I read that [inaudible]
look at this shit dude.
This is Bob Sapp versus Mirko Cro.
Cop Mirko is literally almost
200 pounds lighter than them.
He's actually a hundred.
He's a probably no bullshit.
150 pounds lighter than him,
which is incredible.
And I mean he's,
he just sucks man.
And he's chasing cro cop around and he
gets a hold of him and he like China to
rabbit punches just
trying to dirty box some.
He just wants to me to death.
He sees that big.
It just has to lay one on you and your
and your dumb Mirko was strong enough and
fast enough to keep him off.
Which is the difference
between his style and Ernesto.
Who's throwing Ernesto?
Who?
Who's the better kickboxer
look technically then Mirko.
Oh yeah.
What makes Mirco so dangerous and MMA
is that he's explosive and it'll dart in
and blast you.
He'll take a chance and do something wild.
Where a guy like it was something hard,
something ridiculous shit.
Not just a feeler.
I mean that,
that's,
he wants to,
he will go after you.
Oh I forgot.
I forgot.
He got ball clipped.
You've got Paul clipped it looks
like or something happen there.
Very rarely do you get pokes in pride too.
That was another interesting thing.
This is actually kickbox
fat fingers on fat fingers.
And apparently the way it's designed,
it makes you a curl your hand more,
uh,
keep it curled.
Whereas the UFC ones,
do you feel that the UFC ones
make your hands straightened out?
I never thought about it.
I'll have to check that out next time.
Well,
they say that the pride
ones were like curved.
They had like a curve too actually.
Yeah.
They were actually bent curve
where the UFC ones are straight.
Yeah.
And as,
as you,
especially as a fight goes on,
you've relaxed,
your hands may be a little bit like,
that would be a time where the pride one
would be better because it would keep
them kind of curved.
That makes sense.
Did he hit him with a body shot there?
Backed that up.
I'm talking too much.
People who are listening to this and
watching this are getting two totally
different experiences because uh,
I don't even know who has
the a c there's a body shot,
boom,
left kick to the body and
straight left to the face.
Mirko Cro.
Cop was a fucking savage back then.
Man.
He was one of the most dangerous
guys as far as like sniper strikers.
Yeah.
And then came into MMA
and fought in pride.
Holy Shit.
With us some great fights.
His knockouts and pride are some of the
all time greatest highlight reel head
kick knockouts,
series of your ego of,
of change game.
Uhmm Alexander million ankle boom.
Just blast and dudes with that head kick,
that Russian dude dose Carl's with the,
he came in with the loop,
delete Libris mask on head kicked Blount.
He was treating with Marco
who asked for that fight.
And I remember thinking like,
dude,
this guy's got it.
Oh,
because you know,
Martha was it on,
it wasn't,
it was in our area and I had some
friends that trained over there and uh,
I remember just like I would stop in
there every once in a while and I was just
like,
man,
this guy's,
this guy might might
actually die in this one.
Yeah.
He was amazing man.
Mirko when at that level,
that's like when he was at its very best.
It was either before it was challenging,
fade or ripe right after.
Yeah.
It was somewhere in that area.
Where was him chasing after fade
or couldn't quite beat that guy,
you know,
that guy was the best at that time.
At that time,
you know,
still one of my all time favorites.
Especially now like now
that you know you've,
you've had a chance to like look at his
career and a perspective cause you know,
he decided to step back.
I've been watching some of his old fights,
like I've watched the best of pride
and watch some of the crazy ones.
Oh my God.
And he was,
he was a risk taking motherfucker,
man as a heavyweight champ
risk taken motherfucker.
He wanted to go in there and
he wanted to to finish you.
No ma'am.
No matter what he wanted.
And he wanted to just violently take,
just crush you.
And he would do,
I mean it,
it just seemed like he had that
super killer instinct that,
I mean it's rare.
Who was incredible.
Yeah,
he was,
he was so aggressive and
explosive and the yet unassuming.
Yeah.
It was the weirdest thing.
230 pounds,
20 pounds,
if not,
not buff at all.
Almost like a Chubby kid.
Not even a little buff.
And just like,
I mean,
he could move,
that guy was fast and he hit,
he hit like a,
had a break on the end of his hand.
And it was crazy because he
really started off as a grappler,
but somewhere along the line he became
one of the scariest strikers in MMA.
And one of the guys who was
the most successful striking,
like his fight with cro cop was
basically a kickboxing fight.
They stood the whole time.
Yeah.
I mean there was a few exchanges on the
ground where he was inside a crow cubs
guard,
but for the most part it was
a kickboxing belt that he won.
Yeah,
exactly.
You outset cro,
cop and he just kept cro,
cop backing up.
He kept coming forward
and he's always dangerous,
you know.
And there was fights where
he had to come back to like,
um,
the fight against Fujita where
he got clipped that fight,
did the ad and do the chicken dance.
Yeah.
He did the chicken dance and then,
you know,
15 seconds later for GTAs
out random and slammed him.
And then that just swept him and woo.
That Kamora that reverse a arm bar,
whatever it is.
That was beautiful and it was like the
seconds after getting slammed on his head
and the one of the most
ridiculous suplexes ever
attempted in MMA and random and
if you never saw a random and fight
random in was probably the biggest freak
athlete to ever get into MMA.
And I know that's like
a big statement though,
that guy,
he's a ball of,
of of Alpha.
Of Alpha.
Yeah,
he is just,
I mean he could do things
physically like a whole,
like the whole,
like the hulk to hulk was real.
Yeah,
that's him.
He would go into the octagon before fights
and do this thing where he would jump
up in the air just to kind of freak you
out and he would literally jump to the
top of the octagon.
It was one of the weirdest thing
you've ever seen in your life.
Like you couldn't believe a human
could jump that high and he's not,
not not that tall,
but wide and just long.
It's probably,
is he five 11 or six feet tall?
Maybe five 11 I'd say.
And unbelievably muscular in his prime.
Yeah.
I mean,
he was a superhero and a 26 inch
waist and he looks like Wolverine.
Wolverine was a real person.
He had that build.
Yeah.
And God damn that motherfucker could move.
Randleman would take guys down and take
guys down with these power doubles,
like launched them through the air,
like it was launching
hundreds of pounds he was.
And then,
you know,
the big looping setup
hooks that he would throw,
like you're knocked out cro,
cop picks.
He jumped from halfway across the rings.
Ridiculous,
explosiveness,
athleticism,
power,
speed off the charts.
But seemed like there was only bursts
where he really applied himself,
you know?
Yeah.
You feel like it's one of the curses it
seems like for like these ultra ultra
talented guys.
It's like almost,
it comes too easy and it's
almost like guys that have to,
I've always said like if
you want to learn technique,
like I mean,
and just like trying to learn Jujitsu,
learn from a light guy.
Yeah.
Learn from a guy who has struggle and
really learn how to do it correctly.
You learn from some Kevin Randleman
type cat like that guy can do shit.
You can't do math.
Like still getting around that.
He ain't going to do it.
He just get a can opener you all day.
Yeah.
Just just forget that it's Lou got to
figure out another way to approach this
because you guys are different with
dealing with two different kinds of
vehicles.
That guy's got a fucking Ferrari
and he can do crazy shit.
You can't do that.
You've got to think for
Das buyer aren't going to,
it's weird that a lot of those guys
that are like super ultra talented for
whatever reason,
they don't achieve the same results that
a lot of the guys that are like almost
[inaudible].
It's an uphill battle,
the entire wag.
But along the way they develop these
incredible skills and like perfect example
of a guy who had very few physical
gifts and didn't even take care of his
health.
It was Jeremy Horn.
Yeah.
You know and Jeremy Horn
would eat shitty ass food.
It was never yoked in
lift a weight in his life.
205 damn.
Jeremy Horn had a lot of fights
and he very rarely got hurt.
Yeah.
Very rare.
He got chucked.
The chuck fight was like the
only fight where he got hurt.
That was sad.
It was a blood,
you name it.
It was a different shock.
And Jeremy didn't belong
in that weight class.
There was already a
weight class below that.
He should have been competing at 85.
It was a,
but I think of money thing.
It was a hype thing,
you know?
Well,
yeah,
it was like Chuck's first loss.
Yeah.
It was a fun fight.
The first fight was interesting because,
uh,
Jeremy Caught Chuck with an arm triangle
from the bottom and put him to sleep,
which never happens.
It's so rare.
And if you know how fucking
strong chocolate Dell is,
that's when that becomes
really incredible.
Yeah.
Because chuck is a fucking savage.
He is a very big,
very,
very strong man.
People don't know.
I was like in person.
I saw some of his greatest victories,
like the Tito fights and
Bob Ballou fights and um,
uh,
just you could think of this
so many of them back to,
but the random and fight
another great fight.
Chuck had a way of going
after dudes like the,
the first Tito knock out that
fucking series of hammers he threw.
He was a terrifying guy,
man.
Terrifying.
Especially for Tito that time.
Cause Tito knew.
Yeah,
it was common.
Yeah.
It's,
you don't know it was coming.
He knew that
it was only going to get
worse with no pads on,
you know,
and he though doesn't,
it doesn't like in hit and he,
he's just that kind of guy who,
you know,
I mean he will break under
that kind of pressure.
I think most people will.
But I mean he just,
he wilted pretty bad.
Well it was just a terrible
matchup for him at that time.
And I think Tito was already
having some back problems.
Yeah.
Think Tito's back had been
fucking with them for a while.
I mean,
you got to think he had
a real powerful style.
You know,
Tito had this really aggressive attacking
style and dealing one fucking feed.
That bitch is,
you got to work it like that in the gym,
you know,
and I'm sure if he fought
the way he fought and if he,
if he trained for those kinds of fights,
I bet his training was every bit as
fucking brutal and that's an incredible
amount of punishment for your body.
That's not my coach is the one
who had him there and he just,
I mean that guy trained his ass off
from what my coach has that colony yama.
Yeah.
He uh,
Colin says that Holland's
been around forever.
Yeah.
He's super old school.
Old School respect call.
Get Out of my respect.
You've got an old school team,
man.
Fuck that mean to go from
like Tito's early days.
You know,
dude went hard man.
And I'll tell you what,
you know,
people,
I don't think Tito Ortiz
gets enough respect.
Most people realize that in,
during his era,
he was incredibly dominant.
Even if he lost to chocolate
dow or whoever he lost to
during Tito's era when he
was on top.
When he beat Evan Tanner,
when it,
when he slammed him and
k owed him rest in peace.
Evan Tanner.
Yeah.
When you know,
when he beat Ken Shamrock,
and granted these are not the best
fighters in the world at the time.
Ken had already had a long
career and had a lot of damage,
a CLS,
we're fucked up,
you know,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't matter.
Tito was fucking dominate back
when he would get his hands on you.
He was so strong,
strong,
you know,
with clean wrestling and then hit me like
maybe he didn't punch out hard on the
feet,
but when he got on top of you,
oh yeah.
Oh Man.
He was putting all of his weight and
the elbow is all of his weight into the
punches and him and he was
just on point with that.
In my opinion.
He's like a pioneer of ground
and pound inside the guard.
Definitely because he's one of the
best at doing it inside the guard.
Like everybody,
I say like if I see someone doing a
grounded pound thing and the guard,
I always think,
well,
this guy would do better if he
would get out of this position.
Yeah.
Not Tito.
Tito would fucking smash
guys from inside their guard.
And I think we learned a lot
about horsepower and those fights.
But if you've got that kind of horsepower,
there's certain,
there's like most dudes have a 320
horsepower engine and then you know,
if you're in there with a dude like Tito,
Tito has got a 500 horsepower engine.
Okay.
And you're not going to
hold on one with your legs.
You're sweaty ass tired legs.
And I'm not going to keep that animal
fucking slam and elbows in your face.
But it's just,
that was his time.
And everybody's time is
very limited in that sport.
Of course.
Yeah.
We all have a very limited shelf life.
I mean we're,
we're,
we're going to go back to,
even today,
I mean,
even chuck who was one of
the most durable guys ever,
there's certain point in
time he had to be like,
you know,
that's,
we're gone,
we're done.
I mean that,
that,
that your body gives out,
that button gets pushed too much,
whatever it is.
And it just,
you know,
one day it,
we,
we and most of us want
to go out and our shield,
you know,
so that's just how it ends.
And it's not that pretty,
it's not always pretty.
You know,
it's interesting the,
the volume of strikes that you guys
deal with in the flyweight division,
it's gotta be higher than it
by far than any other division,
right.
If you ever,
has anybody ever compiled it
and tried to see like what the,
what the volume of strikes is?
That's a good,
uh,
someone to do that on the Ugi someone,
someone figured out that someone probably
already has and crunching numbers like
on the data,
this is probably dude's out there.
The remember the rain man of stats.
I only am jumping on on weekends,
but just the amount of like
actual beats that actual go on,
whether it's movement steps,
strikes,
landed and the accelerated aspect of
that in comparison to maybe other weight
classes where they don't move as much.
I wonder if that has an impact on,
you know,
your body getting to a certain point.
It's just saying all right,
we're good.
Yeah.
I landed the fourth most
late kicks in UFC history.
Oh my God.
That's a hell on,
he told me.
And your last fight.
Yeah.
43.
Holy Shit.
Goddamn.
Which Dylan had to kick harder because
if I land 43 kicks should not be walking.
I'm just thinking about 43 kicks and
the body and the guy that was just the
legs.
I got a couple of the body
and a couple of the head.
I think
I come from a Muy Thai.
Jen.
I know you do.
Listen,
I love your footwork too,
man.
You're,
you're a fun guy to watch.
It's constant excitement and uh,
your,
your last fight was fucking bad ass.
I wish I was there.
There was a lot of fun.
Did you fight in Brazil?
Is that where it was once?
What was that like?
Oh Man.
Uh,
I love Brazil and I went out of my way to,
to make the fans appreciate
me and not hate me.
I was the only non non Brazilian
that didn't get booed at wins.
Oh that's beautiful.
And,
and you know,
and of course I knew I would get booted
in the fight cause there's right,
of course,
15,000,
20,000 angry presented in that they,
where do they stay?
They chant.
You're gonna die.
Ooh Mama.
Ooh,
I'm over it.
And you'll know what I think though,
man.
Undeniably you're one of the
best fighters in the world.
Thank you.
And undeniably there.
Mixed martial arts fans,
those people,
when they see a top contender,
his weight class respect,
they appreciate it.
And there's a few guys that have said
stupid shit like shell in Charleston and
can't go on.
Like if chill ever,
like Charles,
not the type to come to me for advice.
But if he ever came to me
for advice and he said,
hey,
a Joe,
they're offering me a
fight against the Brazil.
Vito Belfort in Brazil,
do I go fuck no,
you don't go.
No,
don't eat the food.
And I'm not saying Brazilian
people would poison,
you know,
don't get me wrong,
but one of them might shit they,
they,
they're fucking,
they have a lot of pride.
They are the most intense fans.
And I like it.
I enjoy it.
I was chanting,
you're going to die along with them.
What is it,
the words to that again,
I think it's,
it's
a,
it's m a rrh somewhere.
Somewhere around there
or something like that.
Yeah.
And they,
they just,
I mean,
even in Australia,
American fans,
you've got to get your act together.
You guys,
you guys are half half really
knowledgeable but quiet.
And the other loud half are
douchebags and are just drunk.
But like other other countries,
they might be Douche bags,
but they're all doing it at once.
Like,
you know,
they,
they just become one giant entity of
energy that's just going fucking crazy.
And it,
God,
I love that shit man.
There's nothing like Brazil for that.
No,
nothing like it.
It's,
it's a really life changing experience.
They at,
first of all,
they're there for the first fight,
an hour early,
an hour early.
The place is packed to the gills
there singing songs and shit.
I'm not joking right there.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
You can hear it in the
back and you're like,
wow,
they fucking passion.
And there's so successful.
If you look at Brazil and
the international MMA scene,
I mean fucking across the
board from the old days,
the very first one hoists Gracie to go
over just all these different dudes that
are Anderson Shogun.
You know,
just all throughout the list.
Fabrizio Verdon everywhere.
Vandelay Silva of course.
You know Jesus Christ,
so many Jujitsu guys.
All dope man.
I mean,
you get so many,
there's so many.
And they're still coming.
They're coming more and more and more.
You see seen these guys from,
whether it's a Nova Uniao or you know,
all the different teams,
there's a fucking gang of them over there.
Yeah.
And then we,
when we
were down there,
I didn't get to see it,
but my coach and,
and a few of the guys went and to go one
of the index gym to watch sparring and
Jeeva got Jeeva.
My jujitsu coach do
with the arm collector.
Santana.
Yeah.
He got,
you know,
he like the guy didn't like the guy,
they just go super hard.
And the guy,
the guy hit him with like a spinning heel
kick and hit him in the ribs and just
like separate a rib or
something or hurt him.
And uh,
and they're like,
man,
those guys,
they,
they're fighting.
Like they,
they are going,
they're trying to knock each other out.
Like [inaudible] knock some dude out and
woke him up and the guy kept sparring.
Oh my God.
You know,
it's like,
of course,
if you can survive that and
you're going to survive a fight,
you know,
I mean,
they're down.
They're tough.
They're weight.
They build a tougher product than
I think anywhere else in the world.
Do you think it's just the extreme
poverty that's close by the,
you're getting a lot of like real intense
like need to get the fuck out of there
and elevate your position and this is
an opportunity to become Anderson Silva.
Exactly.
To be,
yeah.
to be Elvis,
you know,
continental,
baller,
you know,
by far I think that then they see
it and they know that that's where,
you know,
the humble beginnings they started at
so they see it and it just makes sense.
It's a straight path.
Yeah,
the straight path.
There's no,
I mean there's there you
just know where to go,
you know,
such a high level of competition there.
It's really interesting to say,
but you know what,
in America you can say the same thing.
There's such a high level of
competition everywhere and MMA there is,
it's,
it's amazing.
It's an amazing time where
you're seeing high level females,
you know,
you're seeing like really high
level MMA fights that are,
that are happening in female divisions
are going to have to expand female
divisions to the UFC.
One of my training
partners to grow up my gym.
That's to the INVICTA champ.
Carla Esparza and I mean she is,
she's fucking bad ass.
She is.
I see her beat dude's up
all the time and I mean,
she is fucking mean.
Yeah,
she's fucking bad.
I mean like in the gym I've had to,
I've had to crack her
heart and just be like,
hey,
she's like,
stop it.
She trying to kill you.
Yeah.
Like I told you once,
I told you twice if you do that again,
I'm going to,
I'm going to drop you.
Do you feel like you're in a John
Wayne movie when that should happen?
We got a smack a bitch and go,
hey,
hey listen.
I know you've been fucking up some dude's.
If he ain't fucking with me,
I'm not trying to fuck you up.
I'm just just,
just [inaudible] we're
trying to go over technique.
Carla don't hit me that hard pop
and I hit her back and she goes,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I'm like,
okay,
well some people get really intense man.
They were really into it.
But that's,
you know,
obviously it's a style of training
and some people disagree with it.
Like they think that
like to shoot box it up,
you're going to punch your card too many
times before you even get into yeah.
Into a ring or a cage or headgear.
Yes,
that's what I do.
But does that really make an impact
because they say that head gear,
even though you don't
get cut as up as much,
you're,
you're still,
it's the impact on the brain.
The actual impact doesn't change.
It gets cushioned a bit.
Yeah.
But it almost rattles you more.
That could be true.
I don't know.
I just,
you know,
I'm no scientist.
I don't take my,
I have no idea.
I just,
it,
it keeps,
it makes me think I'm protected.
Yeah.
So I'll wear it.
Well,
it also,
do you,
do you practice a training
with guys that you could trust?
Do you like do you or do you treat
with anybody and train with anybody?
No,
we,
we've got,
we've got a tight knit team.
It's an interesting thing,
isn't it,
that MMA over like maybe the past decade
or so has really developed a way to
professionally approach things.
Whereas there was a lot of
variation just 10 years ago and,
and training methods and a lot of
people did a lot of stupid shit.
We've got,
you know,
we bring in wrestlers,
I have,
we have the wrestling coach that
bring in restaurants to work with me.
I have the guys that are on the team,
but then I also have
guys that are just moy,
Tai,
Romeo,
Don's ice,
my,
you know,
he the guys,
one of the best us kickboxers of all time,
you know,
and then people don't know who he is.
He went to 115 pounds,
but he'll sleep at any
heavyweight out there.
Prompts here.
He's the guy,
he's,
he's incredible.
What is his name again?
Romeo Danza.
And is he going to fight MMA or just he's,
he's just moy.
Tai,
you know,
he's,
he said a bad string of luck
the past couple of fights,
but I'm,
and he's just incredible.
And,
and,
but like I said that then
a high level more time.
Now he's two,
right?
Yeah.
I've got the Moitai the rest thing that
Jujitsu and I work at all separate,
all with guys I trust that are my
size and then we can combine it.
Who's the mass amount of your camp?
Is it you and Collin?
Do you work it out together?
Colin?
Colin Jeeva for the Jujitsu and then,
um,
Romi for,
for,
you know,
cause he,
he holds pads for me,
you know,
we'll go like literally will go
like an hour straight hold and pads.
Um,
and then no rope rope,
no Romeo,
Don's,
I don't mean to dance.
Yeah.
Romy arms over at Millennia.
And then you have for
wrestling of Sheldon Kim.
Romy is another old school guy,
right?
Yeah.
Hobby Vasquez.
Old School.
Super Old.
I mean,
he was like motherfuckers right there.
And he was a black belt that like what
16 and a long ass time ago went to and
there was no black belts.
Yeah,
I mean,
I never rolled with Hobie,
but Hobie a rolled a,
I say awesome role a couple of times at
John Jock in person and watching his Jiu
Jitsu.
She just is incredible.
He talks to you the whole time.
It's a constrictor and just tells you
what's going to happen and like in like a
super sometimes annoying way.
So good.
He'll show you after what,
what,
what it did.
But it's like,
Dude,
oh my God,
you're so good.
It's crazy.
Eddie Bravo told me a hobby Vasquez story.
The first time you ever went
to a tournament saw Havi
he saw this dude running
sprints up the stairs and he was like,
what the fuck?
Who the hell is going to have
to fight this fucking guy?
Eddie comes in,
they would flip flop side
and you can even do a sit up.
I'll,
he's watching this fucking
dude run sprints upstairs.
I think he,
I think he lost a hobby twice,
I want to say.
Almost caught him in a twister wants,
but him and Havi had some crazy battles.
Yeah.
Hobbies.
Uh,
elite,
elite Jujitsu guy.
It was very,
very rarely do.
There's,
there's black belts and then there's
the super elite and you know,
like,
like the hobbies or the Jeeva is,
or the,
you know,
the,
um,
you know,
the name off a million
different Gracie's hobbies.
Also a guy that he was a
pretty public about his,
uh,
his knee injury.
He had a pretty fucking serious
knee injury and he lost his title.
Yeah.
And um,
what the fuck was it that he fought?
Goddamn,
and I can see him right
in front of me right now.
He fought in the UFC as well.
That guy.
God Damn,
I gotta look it up now.
Sorry.
Hobby Hobby is listening.
He's like,
what the fuck?
I look you guys.
How do you not remember?
Bitch?
I can't remember.
There's not enough room.
All right.
There's a thing called a,
I know Robert [inaudible],
Robert and Stephen be at my
theme and I don't know that,
that,
that was the fight,
don't think.
No,
no.
Um,
uh,
Robert just stayed out of his guard.
Yeah.
Robert,
uh,
fought a very smart fine again,
him.
Emerson,
right.
Yeah.
That was another guy who,
who,
uh,
who had incredible skill and could
have been really good burrito crane.
The wasted it.
Yeah.
He fought Alberto Crane of blew out
his ACL and then kept fucking fighting
through the rest of the
fight and his shit was gone.
So his leg was buckling every time we
tried to move mangling the inside of his
knee while he did that.
And he just really always had
problems with it after that.
You know,
he had so many problems with the,
exactly.
He got mad at me that
I brought it up in a,
uh,
telecast once and I didn't meet,
I mean he was,
he talked about it in interviews.
I didn't think that I was like naming
something that people weren't aware of,
but I was saying that someone should kick
his legs cause he's had problems with
his knees and he was like,
that's kind of fucked up.
And I see his point.
It is Kinda fucked up.
But it's also true with public knowledge.
It's not like you hide
that and like you told me,
don't tell anybody,
but I fucked my knee up.
Coaches are already going
to have that thought of,
and I just,
I hate saying shit like that,
but it is what you should do.
Yeah.
I mean it's like if you,
if you were fighting in a movie like
game of Thrones and there was like the
noble choice and if it's not
knowable to kick a guy's legs,
if his knees are problematic,
but with a fucking Boa constrictor,
like that,
dude,
you got to take every
advantage you can get anyway,
right?
Yeah.
You got to just,
just try and put a chink in
that armor somewhere so it,
you know,
the body doesn't move right.
If you can just start to hurt something.
Yeah.
So he got mad that I brought that up,
but it's not that I don't love you buddy.
Yeah.
I love it.
Hobby.
I do love that dude.
I was bummed out that he was mad at me,
but I get it.
I understand it.
It's one of those weird things where
like people have been upset at me if I've
done commentary on them losing and like
spectacular fashion that like I sort of
like emphasized it made it suckier than
it even had to be kind of your job.
I know I don't,
but I don't mean to like
everybody thinks it's you know,
or they suspect that it's personal.
It's no way you have,
you get excited about doing
your job that's apparent.
Yeah.
It's a weird job though.
You know?
It's a,
it's an especially weird
job if you haven't done it,
you know,
cause like that's true.
I'm doing commentary and MMA.
I never had an MMA fight ever come close.
I wasn't even thinking about it.
You know,
I almost fought Wesley snipes but I was
pretty sure he didn't know what he was
doing.
This thought I was just going to grab him,
take him down and shut out.
I felt like,
I'm like,
how's I going to keep
me from grabbing him?
Like what are you going to do?
Are you going to be
going to be really slick?
Yeah.
It takes a long time.
We have a long time to dance.
I'll grab you.
I'm going to grab you.
That's all I thought of.
I didn't think like I'm,
I'll start fighting MMA,
you know,
to do commentary on a
guy like Anderson Silva.
Like who the fuck am I
to say what he should do?
I have zero credibility.
It's a ridiculous
position for me to begin.
Damn you.
You're just like the refs man.
He had no business being there.
It's true.
I have no business being there.
And yeah,
the rest I said the judges,
the rest happened at the reps actually.
Yeah,
for the most part.
I mean there's some
mistakes like Mazda God,
he takes a lot of heat I think.
I think it's a fucking tough,
it's a tough job.
It's a tough gig.
And I think there's excellent
guys like in my opinion right now,
um,
big John McCarthy is
always top of the heat.
Always.
That's the gold standard.
And then there's herb dean
who I think is right up there.
I think Josh Rosenthal,
that was Josh Rosenthal is right up there,
man.
Man,
I'm really bummed out
about his legal situation.
He got a,
I don't want to blow up his spot,
whatever.
I don't need to talk
about his legal problems,
but he's a great guy.
We start kind of luck.
I mean he's a good dude.
He just did something that's only
illegal because the world's run by cunts.
Yes.
Lost my answer.
One thing's for sure my dad were firearm,
whatever.
Great Dude.
I love the guy and he's
a great referee to yeah,
he,
you can count on him like does a few guys
like you find out they're going to be
the referee.
You Go,
good.
This is going to be a good fight.
Do you have say over who
referees your fights?
I know.
I'm just waiting for the day that Kim
winds up walks in and I can just raise my
hand and go,
hey,
this is not happening.
I think Kim does a pretty good job,
man.
I think,
I think she has a real hard
time with big people though.
You know,
like what was her last fight
where this two fucking,
oh it was gone.
Zaga and peewee Herman.
I was like,
that is crazy.
Like that's dangerous.
Yeah.
And for the fighters.
She's like 120 pounds maybe.
Right.
And Gonzaga is two 16 through to 60
built like a fucking gorilla that someone
took in a lab and Berge with a human.
I mean when he like gets in
front of the camera and goes,
wow,
I'm making crazy faces and shit.
I mean he's saga looks like
he's some crazy caveman.
What's he just bothers me cause she's
made some bad choices and the fact that I
don't want to hear a woman's
voice in the cage there.
You just pick again,
just just yapping at
me while I'm fighting.
Trying to fight,
prepare for the feminists to
be coming at you full boar.
Especially feminist MMA fans in the,
it's a huge,
huge part of the market.
He's going to have to apologize for you
now and I'm probably probably both in
trouble right now.
Shut our phones off the
Dana can't Texas my dad,
he'll fucking shut the internet down.
Who called Vegas?
I'm getting a string call.
Lorenzo.
Shut the internet down.
We're all going in.
Ian,
I'm going to get us in trouble.
It's funny man.
But I see how you would want.
Definitely if you have
that opinion about it,
whether it's a woman or a man,
if you have an opinion about a
referee that you don't think is good,
I would think that would be important
to like make sure that that's one less
thing you have to think about.
Did they give you like
a hard time about that?
Is that like pretty easy to do?
I don't know.
I've never,
I've never had a complaint about it.
So I know that's been in
dispute in boxing matches.
Like there's certain reps that are slower
to break things up and let guys fight
out of clinches,
you know?
And then there's other
bar wraps that don't,
they don't tolerate Nyesha.
I've never,
uh,
I've never seen it happen and UFC,
so I don't know.
That's a good question.
I'm sure it's going to happen or it has
happened and that they've taken care of
her.
I'm sure Bert has has
made it quick work of it.
You know,
that guy does his job well.
It's really,
it's an interesting situation and a
lot of people don't even aware of that.
Like people go,
what does UFC fixed your fucking judging?
They can't do anything.
Yeah,
it's,
it's the state athletic commissions
that control all the judging.
Exactly.
It's getting better I think sometimes.
Sometimes I think it's getting better.
Every now and then a flight
comes along and you're like,
wait,
what?
You know,
come on man.
Like there's some shit you guys are
not taking into consideration here.
Yeah.
You know there's,
there's a few fights where he just go,
man,
I'm,
I'm missing something here.
I don't get how that was.
What did you see that I
didn't see or not Sam,
I'm just,
I really believe this and this
sounds like stupid bullshit,
but I think that they should
consider having a one extra vote.
One extra judge and that one extra judge.
So it'd be the Internet.
That's what I think.
I think you should allow fans to register
and vote and allow them to like you
could rate someone who judges
the way you read a Yelp account.
Like all this food tastes like ass.
Yeah.
Like all this guy judges like shit.
And then you get a few red flags if you
made some questionable decisions and
then you get removed from the queue and
you can't judge anymore or you can't
judge a high level fights where you have
to prove yourself or whatever the fuck
you got to do.
But I think having that as a
fourth judging that May 4th option,
maybe even coming to it if it's
a a close disputed decision.
If it's close,
let's go to the Internet judge,
let's see what that was and then you know,
take that into consideration or,
or what,
I mean,
I don't know how you would factor it in.
What would be most valuable,
whether it's the in person judges or the
Internet judge because it's a different
experience not being there as well.
Maybe give him half a point.
Yeah.
Like is that,
does that make sense?
That it's a different experience watching
it cage side as it is watching it on
television and it almost wouldn't be
fair if they only watch it on television.
It's completely different.
There's so much,
there's so much you can't see.
Your judges have screens in front of them,
don't they?
Yeah.
And you can see they do have screens
if they want to catch angles they do.
Now.
It's something that we complained about
for a long fucking time before they
finally gave in and started giving them
screens because there's certain angles
where if someone,
if I'm on one side of the cage and there's
a ground fight going on in the exact
opposite side of the cage,
I can't see what's going on.
And if a guy has his back
to me and the other guy has,
I don't know what he's,
I have to see a monitor is,
that's the only way to see it.
Exactly.
So finally judges get to see that
because for the longest time some of the
questionable decisions could
be boiled down to that.
Like the,
you didn't get a good angle to see
exactly was happening the whole time.
So in a close,
like ten nine sort of a situation
where it could go either way,
there's a lot of fights where
could kind of go either way.
Yeah.
Well after the round was over like fuck,
they got to choose a winner here.
Yeah.
And then would are,
or how,
I mean,
how much do you do refs or a judges go
off punch that so they know them right
away.
You think they know them at all?
That's the kind of thing that
that needs to get figured out.
Like we have them.
I know,
but I'm saying that,
that they,
they should want that
information to judge a fight.
I don't think they get it.
I'm pretty sure they don't get it.
So like when we're,
I think that could influence them,
but I think that's why they don't get it.
I need to find that out for sure.
I should ask my dope,
my Kohlberg,
I'll text him.
That's how strong this is while this is
going on and it might go over and we'll
be on ancient if they don't
know the numbers and that's
bullshit cause they need
to know they need to see those numbers.
Yeah.
It seems like that would
be something just like the,
um,
just like the monitors,
that would be a no brainer,
but it's hard,
man.
It's hard to get change.
Change is fucking hard,
you know,
especially when it's run by the state.
Yes.
And that's what people need to understand.
It's not,
this is not as simple as like
the UFC needs to implement the,
no,
you're dealing with a whole bureaucracy.
He dealing with people that
don't want to lose their jobs.
You're dealing with,
it's really tough to fire people
because it's a government gig.
Yes.
It's not the same,
you know,
and that's a part of it.
Like there's a lot of people that are
judges that I like as human beings,
I always say hi to them.
They're very nice people.
I just don't think they're
qualified to do what they're doing.
And I think,
I think there should be look
at them and see that yeah.
There,
there should be some sort of,
um,
some sort of
like absolute baseline knowledge
that you have to have had.
You have to have some experience
in some sort of combat sports.
I think that fighters are,
judges should have been
fighters with so many fights.
It's a good idea,
you know,
or,
or at least hire a,
a,
a standup judge,
a wrestling judge and the judge in a,
in a grand,
you get to judge or you know,
some sort of,
and then have a fourth MMA.
I don't know.
Just they,
they didn't,
they need to figure it out.
Something because everyone has to have
knowledge and I think the entire sport
instead of just one facet of it.
Yeah,
I think you're right too.
But man,
if you had just to Jitsu judges,
those motherfuckers would be,
every five was the Juju.
So let's,
when me and my friend,
he didn't know he can posses God,
my friend.
You know,
we disagree.
Everybody.
There was so many Brazilians were
mad when Haji Gracie got cut.
Yeah.
They,
they're fucking legend.
He's just so good.
And it's one more five,
four,
two oh five Mr Deno whites,
they're like,
they all wanted him.
You know,
they're so loyal and
like a name like Gracie,
that's his royalty and mixed
martial arts as you get.
Fuck Prince Charles.
All right.
That's real royalty.
The Gracie name is Royal's.
It is.
So when Dana Cut Heidrick Gracie,
it's like,
well,
she's just,
what?
How dare you,
he's a dude that I don't
think she'd be fine in one 85.
I look at hydro and he's so big.
He's so tall and it is murder for
that motherfucker to make one 85.
I his like what he looked like
after he had weighed in like,
Jesus,
that dude,
I mean,
that is really hardcore weight cutting.
That guy's doing.
Yeah.
He's a big boy.
Fuck yeah.
Yes man.
The weight cutting is his.
Yeah,
he's big dude.
When you're around him,
like how does that guy way one 85?
How's that even possible?
Because he,
I see a lot of guys like that and I
mean at every weight that is just like,
wow.
Yeah.
No one better exemplifies it then.
Who,
uh,
GSP is pretty bad.
Anthony Rumble.
Johnson.
Yeah.
He's,
I mean he made one,
well we barely made one mistake.
One 70 but now he's
fighting it in heavyweight.
Yeah,
it's okay.
And he's beating guys like our Lawsky.
You missed,
you missed wait at 70.
So they kicked out a 70.
They kick you out of a weight class,
which I don't knew that was possible.
Then you miss wait at the next higher
for the 15 pounds higher weight class by
12 pounds.
So you missed your original
weight by 2027 pounds.
You're just being an asshole now.
I met him in between fights
once his back when he was,
uh,
one of the scariest guys in
the welterweight division.
He was just coming up.
He had knocked out Tommy
Burns and remember that fight.
Yeah,
but ruthless fight man,
he was absolutely brutal.
Tommy was coming off of the
ultimate fighter and he was,
there is moments in fighters'
careers where they just appear like,
oh my God,
this is the motherfucker right here.
And he was one of them.
And that moment when he bursts on the
scene and knocked out that Tommy Burns,
who that was like his coming out party,
I was like,
this kid is fucking powerful.
That's what it was.
He went after people and he just,
it just physically just crushed.
And he was so big for one 70.
Didn't even make sense.
No,
I met him in between fights.
He was a,
at one of the,
um,
I think it was in Denver.
Came down and he wasn't competing,
so he was giant.
I go,
what do you way?
And he goes,
I'm about to 30 to 20 to 30.
Like how watch,
he was huge.
It was fucking gigantic.
That's,
I mean,
the foot,
that's a 60 pound weight cut.
And he's building a heavyweight too.
I mean he be like,
looked like it didn't look like,
man,
you shouldn't be fighting heavyweight.
It was like,
yeah,
you can be a heavyweight.
How the fuck did you get one 70?
Cause he's,
he's tall too.
It's not like he's a
short super thick guy.
He's just a big man.
Yeah.
That's,
that's just gotta be
unbelievably bad for your body.
It's just gotta be unbelievably bad for
your body when you have that Nice nutty
seesaw.
Right.
Yeah.
I honestly probably think it takes a year
or two off your life every time you do
it.
I mean it's like I cut the most I've
ever cut was 18.8 and last 20 hours.
It's a different thing for you though too,
because of the percentage of your body
weight as opposed to like a guy like
Johnson who's 50 60 pounds heavier.
But as I'm saying,
I was in Florida.
Oh my God.
When I thought deep Demetrius the second
time I cut 18.8 pounds the last 80 or
last 20 hours.
I don't even know what
it was before that was,
I just,
that that one was really screwed me up.
But when you go to a place like Florida,
how much time do you spend adjusting to
the moisture in the air and the change
in the environment?
Uh,
I don't,
I mean I don't really,
it doesn't really bother me.
What about an altitude
if you have to fight it?
Like Denver?
I never fought in the
high altitude before.
Wow.
But I mean that'd be a wild place
to wash some fucking fly whites.
Cheese,
man.
I wonder,
cause heavyweights in Denver are crazy.
Like every time you have a
heavyweight fight in Denver,
it's like these poor fucking,
God's got just got drugged
and pushed into a cage.
You gotta fucking dark your neck,
man.
People don't understand man.
If you've never been to Denver,
that shit is up there.
That's a mile high city,
legit.
And the people that live there
have more endurance than you.
If you get used to that too.
Like that's why those guys
trained in Albuquerque or,
but he goes up to big bear.
When you get used to that shit,
it makes your body like super enriched
with oxygen and red blood cells.
You have all this endurance.
Well that's it.
But my girlfriend outside,
she,
she lives in Reno is always in tile.
Uh,
so you're always up there high.
And then she's,
I mean she's always,
she comes out here more but,
but you have to go up there to train.
Uh,
no,
I'm going to start in more cause I,
cause she's up there and I
actually genuinely liked this one.
So I would think that for a guy like you,
like there'd be a real benefit and
training at a place like big bear.
Well,
I don't make enough
money to pay for a camp,
you know,
and I do do see Vac,
which is that,
I don't know if you've ever yeah,
no.
What Seabeck explain
that though for it is,
uh,
let me try it and be split at 10.
Like Bj has.
No,
it would have,
or the sleeping bag.
It's an egg.
And that egg you sit
in and you're getting,
like you're sitting in a
recliner and basically it's,
it does the elevation,
but it's,
it's changes to temperature,
density of air elevation.
Um,
a few,
a few different things where it
makes your body at a cellular level,
flex and expel all the bad stuff and
you're just ready to suck and you feel
amazing.
Like you'll shoot from,
from sea level up to 25,000 feet within
20 seconds and then shoot back down and
then up.
And they do this rhythmic stuff to it.
And you have why you do
breathing exercises and it,
um,
I mean,
why am I only hearing about this
for the first time right now?
I'm so excited.
I'm the,
I was the first real fighter
just starting to me and now,
I mean,
you've got a lot of guys are
doing it in Newport beach.
I mean this is something I bought.
Okay.
It,
what'd you call it again?
See Back,
look up.
Uh,
meanwhile cut to 10 months from now,
Joe Rogan caught up and,
uh,
sent Newport beach.
They get it.
That hoax ever,
I got tricked into going
into a fucking egg.
Yeah,
there's totally a hoax
heard and I love it man.
I'm sorry.
So how do you say it again?
Seabeck see back EAC.
Yeah,
Dunno.
Vac.
And it's a,
I go to a cent in Newport beach and it,
I mean it's,
I'll do 20 minutes sessions,
I'll do three of them and they just pound.
I pound out,
you know,
a lot of like this for the good,
9.5 ph or whatever while I'm in there.
And it just,
I feel amazing.
And then I do breathing
exercises while I'm in there,
so I'll hold my breath.
And what it does is when
you shoot up an elevation,
you're already full of oxygen
and it stretches your lungs.
Like why?
It's,
there's no other way to get this
feeling that I've ever felt.
It literally stretches your lungs out,
then you
and then breathe again.
It's like,
what am I having a hard
time finding a seat back.
What?
See Back Newport beach.
Just Google.
Yeah.
Google see back or see back a scent.
A Sci,
am I spelling it right?
A S C a Vac?
No,
it's just a separate [inaudible].
Yes.
What's that?
A sense?
See Vac,
Newport beach,
a sense vac.
But am I,
am I spelling it right?
Sca Vac?
Yeah,
but nobody see backs is just one word.
C O C and then Vac.
That's Literacy Vac.
Okay,
so you back new port beach.
Oh,
okay.
CVA.
See that's what it is.
So it stands for something.
What does it stand for?
I have no idea.
A sense seevak but yeah,
I mean it's,
it's something that has been around for a,
it's been around for awhile.
Powerful five star review on Yelp.
They've just a Yelp,
some amazing.
They've just started to really
catered towards athletes more.
Tito goes,
I've been going for a while now.
Wow.
So what is the process?
How does the uh,
how's the actual thing
you can go with your body?
You go in and you sit in
the pod and then as it,
as you build up,
there's different levels.
Um,
the,
the fluctuations in the pressure,
the temperature,
the elevation,
you know,
the,
the density of the air,
it just makes your body just heal faster.
You get rid of swelling.
I mean,
it did,
has a list of stuff.
I mean,
you read on there,
uh,
what it does and I can't
really put my finger on it.
It just makes me feel amazing.
It makes my cardio going.
If
the sounds like walls,
magnet bracelet son haven't check it out.
Cycle variations in adaptive
control conditioning.
Okay.
That's what they're calling it.
Building the new Super Athlete,
men's journal.com.
And it's in,
in this.
It works.
It works for me.
I believe you,
dude.
I'm only fucking with you man.
Much respect.
I'm just joking.
But what they're saying is this,
uh,
this,
this is called the power of,
it's an article that's in a men's Journal
magazine and the article is building
the new super athlete and
the first sentence is the
power of the pod and it says
Heather Henniker owns and runs what could
be considered a gym of the future in
Newport beach,
California.
The machine does all the
work at her ascent facility.
The training consists of showing up
and settling into one of her three
stationary CBAC pods
for a 20 minute session.
The air pressure inside,
we'll Jojo,
which means sea level and about 22,500
feet with 200 to 400 pressure changes in
between when you hit maximum altitude
or rather the air pressure equivalent,
you take a rapid nose dive back to Earth
akin to racing up to the top of the
uncle Gog gras.
I don't know what that is on,
on call a,
Guya.
Why did you have to be so obscure,
crazy person?
You couldn't say [inaudible] Heather
it fuck head Heather treme together.
Uh,
and jumping off the 36 year old Hinkler
said that the pod is the only thing that
has kept her rum.
Boyd Arthritis at bay and that
she left her job in finance.
Sanker lifesaving.
It's into this and saw her business nearly
go under until word starts spreading
around the California jock.
Great.
Fine Dude.
Welcome to the California job.
You're,
you're,
you're part of the,
wow.
You're in the California Joc Grapevine.
I don't know if that's good or not.
It's a tricky one,
right?
When someone calls you a jock.
Yeah.
She says the majority of her
clients are professionals,
athletes.
And the first thing it says UFC fighters
and it says major league baseball
player and dirty comedian.
I'm coming,
I'll go there.
You've got to try that shit.
Come on down.
Many times you go a week,
three days a week.
It's death to get down there though.
Yeah.
Well,
and supposedly it cures veneers
and they kept telling Dana,
you got to come try it.
You gotta come and try it.
I had vertigo for like
six months in my life,
a while back.
Here's nearest,
how's it cure my nears again?
I don't know.
I don't,
I didn't build it in as it or bracelet
with a rubber band and the day they sign
I told them to just give it a shot.
It,
it makes me feel better.
So,
well it sounds like there's
something happening.
It's not,
it's not like,
yeah,
it sounds like also,
uh,
it's getting a lot of people
that are excited about it,
which finally people are
starting to see it and they're,
they're,
they're starting to see that the results,
although I do have to say,
we were talking about Shane Carlin,
much respect Shankar went
much loved Shane Carlin,
big Shank Cohen fan as a
human being and as a fighter.
But that mother fucker was trying to tell
me that that rubber band work for him.
He had a rubber band with a magnet on
who's telling me that it's really helping
my balance.
Like touch,
touch,
nothing that's in your head that,
that those guys,
the guys who have been in power
balance so crazy from there.
From my area.
And there's a bunch of them now,
right?
Yeah.
But I'm saying power
balance that that coverage,
the one at least was done
by when they get in jail.
Did they have to go to jail?
I don't think so.
Did they get away?
I mean I know there was
some like crazy losses,
whether there was them or someone else,
you just had to get money or
they had to stop doing something.
And I know,
I know went under,
but they made a boatload
of money while they could.
Well,
if you sold something that gave you the
kind of confidence that made you believe
that,
I mean is that a product?
Cause if you got all
those fucking positive,
you know,
you look at like those stupid rubber band.
Thanks man.
It's so many people were
telling me how great they are.
I want them just to wedges just to,
just to where it's all people.
So for one I can try to get
the sponsorship out of it.
Oh,
there you go.
That's fine.
I didn't,
I thought it was bullshit,
but if it did actually help
because everybody else had them on,
I was wearing.
Do you know the only reason why
I was willing to believe outlook?
I've been willing to believe
a lot of dumb shit in my life.
Psychics and fucking Tarot card
readers and I've been leading,
willing to believe a lot of stupid shit.
But the reason why I didn't believe in
this one when it got down to it was that
the dude who was trying
to demonstrate it on me,
he was trying to do carnival tricks.
Yeah.
Put your arm out like this.
Now resist.
Okay,
now I'm going to put the bracelet on
you and put your arm out like this.
Resist.
I'm like,
that's not the same position.
Like go.
We were up here.
Let's go bring my arm back to here.
Okay,
we're back here again.
Yeah,
go ahead.
No,
you weren't there before.
Yes.
I was like,
what are you doing?
Like you guys are playing carnival.
They were doing leverage tricks.
Exactly like trying to like get
me to pick him up with my hand.
Like what are we doing?
Like you're holding your hand next to
your waist to try to prove strength.
This is one way to prove strength.
Stupid.
Yeah.
Put some weights on a stack and let's
see if I can lift the same amount or less
or more,
whatever.
That's the only way you
can't do a carnival.
Treg so I go,
what are you guys doing?
Like w who taught you how to do this?
I go,
is this like did they teach you?
And then they got like real
weird with me and I was like,
is this,
come on man,
you're trying to make some money.
I've seen people try and
make some money before,
but they teach you how to do this.
I'm like,
cause this is the second person that I've
ever met that has these wristbands for
sale that wants to thumb wrestle.
They want to like keep going.
You get you in some weird yesi position.
Exactly.
Okay,
we'll try and lift me up now.
It's like when what?
It was ridiculous.
Yeah.
And the guy wasn't even that good at it.
You know,
I resisted it and I'm like,
come on man,
you're not even doing it right.
At least at least do it right.
If you're going to,
if you're going to try
and sell me this crap.
It's one of those things where people
want to believe that there's a rubber band
that you could put on that
makes you feel better.
Yeah.
Like slap that bitch on.
I'm going to be ripped and good
looking and tell Dan is straighten up.
My shockers,
my shockers are out of line.
I didn't know what it was.
I was taking yoga.
It was really a waste of time.
I just needed a rubber band with a little
hollow ground and the middle of it put
me back in center in tune.
So how long have you been doing this?
Three times a week thing.
And the CVIC pod.
Oh Man.
Since uh,
before I got in UFC.
By the way,
this is not sponsored by Cva right now.
People going,
oh,
oh see the product placement.
You worked your friends.
Nope.
This just spontaneous.
You've got to bring
Joe down to try it out.
I'd love to except I can't get
down there without a helicopter.
Yeah.
Cause it takes her never,
I just quit.
I'll just pull over the
side road and go to sleep.
But I haven't done a new port beach.
People don't know.
It's a joke.
I went to visit a yeah,
I went down to a affliction and a
back when Tom was working there.
Yeah.
And uh,
I went to visit him.
I said,
yeah man,
I'll come vizio come hang out.
Yeah.
It took two hours.
Two hours.
That's the norm.
That's not even Orange County.
Seal beach is seal beach is still
La County I think 40 minute drive.
I mean it should have been
a 40 minute drive ed most.
And I was like,
this is just ridiculous.
Then they do that every day
and it wasn't even like,
it was an off time.
It was like three in the
afternoon or two in the afternoon.
It wasn't even,
my dad drove from my family dealership
in debt like downtown La next to staple
center.
The Toyota dealership.
It's my families.
He would drive from there down to Laguna
Niguel and then to San Clemente after
we moved to San Clemente on the beach for
30 years there for some really fucking
long time.
How old were you when you moved?
You lived on the beach
like right on the beach?
Yeah,
like yeah,
like I walk on my balcony and I could be,
it could be,
it could be two in the morning.
I could grab a group of people and run
and jump in the water naked and run back
in the house without getting caught.
Wow.
How old were you then when
you guys moved to the beach?
We moved there when I was 16 or 17 and
I believe and we do find in any way that
that had a change in your,
in your demeanor at all,
like being by the water?
No,
cause I already had lived
in Laguna Niguel like,
like a couple of miles from the beach.
I was at the beach.
That's
where our whole little fight crew came
from was Salt Creek beached in Dana point
was that was our beach.
Like,
what are you doing in our beach?
Like beat it,
you know,
be the cook.
We had a bunch of pro surfer
friends and bodyboard friends and,
and you would just bully people and
kick them off the beach and throw water
balloons,
you know,
and like it bad it now.
It always not really.
It was kind of fun.
It was our beach though.
It was different,
you know?
That's so douchey though.
I just want to use the ocean,
man.
We were such to be recessed Douche bag.
Is there a difference in uh,
being by the water all the
time and living at the water?
Yes.
I've always wondered,
like for me there is,
I have a friend was a beach house and it
costs like 4 million bucks and it looks
like it should be like 50.
It's fucking crazy.
It was like,
this is not a $4 million house man.
And you're right next
door to the neighbor.
Like this is the nuttiest thing ever.
Like,
how the fuck did somebody get you
to pay for $1 million for this?
Yeah.
You could have like a castle in Colorado.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You could have a hundred acres with elk
wandering through your yard instead.
You're not jammed up on your neighbor.
But he was like,
it doesn't matter when you
get up and you see the ocean,
you look out your window to see the ocean.
And he goes,
I'm on vacation every day in my life.
Yeah.
He goes,
I look out there,
I hear that water and
it just chills me out.
Yeah.
For Sleep.
The water,
I mean,
my dad's a waterman.
He,
his whole life has revolved around
surfing and fishing and traveling.
Like that's like his passions,
you know.
Um,
demand fish,
fear.
My Dad,
you know,
he's his spear fishing,
uh,
any sort of phishing spear phishing,
some wild shit,
man.
He's,
he's,
uh,
my friend Aubrey,
the CEO of on it just got back from
two and some spear fishing and fun.
And he was saying,
it's like hunting underwater
while you hold your breath.
It's,
it's such a different thing.
Yeah.
And there's a lot more creatures.
Don't wanna eat you,
you know,
it starts to come soon up next to you.
But like you know like living on the
beach at as a senior in high school,
you know,
he was never home.
My parents are getting
divorced at that point.
I had his brand new car to drive
brand new Porsche drive around.
Oh my God.
And he let you drive a Porsche
when you were in high school?
No,
no,
no.
I would,
I just dream it.
Do you know how many people right now?
I just know he didn't know how
he found out it was driving it,
but I would just like an evil character
in a fucking teeny bopper movie.
I was a horrible kid thinking about it.
Like there was like a
16 candles type movie.
I really feel like the
ultimate bad character,
but then you know what?
They'd probably be a girl in the movie
and you fall in love with her and you
would change for her.
That's what's happening right now.
Yeah.
That's a bit of review.
Like
just thinking about your driving your
dad's Porsche around living in the fucking
beach and shit.
And kicking guys asked is like,
what a constantly,
and it,
my dad would bring,
he would go kill fish,
you know,
big tuna or whatever had in Mexico and
come back with a whole fish whole to,
and just literally we would eat it.
They don't get any fresher than that.
I mean,
he's cutting up,
he's gutting it and then
giving you a Sushi is amazing.
I've never done any tuna fishing,
but my friend Tommy did and he said
they ate Tunis Sashimi on the boat.
He said,
it's the most ridiculous thing.
You can't even believe how good it tastes.
It's,
it's a different,
it's a whole different,
and I mean
to now it's a,
it's a fucking torpedo.
A muscle.
I mean,
those are,
that's the best fighting
fish in the ocean.
Tuna,
albacore like that.
Rent those,
those,
those g,
the jacks,
you know,
maybe like yellow tail.
But tuna is the best.
But,
um,
and then also the best
eating drought was fun.
The pretty,
but you know,
we're selfish.
You know,
there was a fun,
pretty bad,
I mean,
tune is unbelievably delicious.
Especially,
it's,
it's so delicious that it's preferred raw.
Yeah.
Does that mean tuners preferred
raw more than anything?
The Japanese,
it paid over a million
dollars for one fish.
I love Sushi.
How's that possible?
You should not sure she makes it.
No.
Why?
You can Google that shit.
You can't Google like,
listen,
this is at least 50 people listen to us.
I have to be really careful
about telling the truth.
All right.
Um,
largest amount paid for a tuna.
Yeah,
but they regularly get like 30,
$40,000 for a tuna catch.
Right?
If you go out,
like out of Nova Scotia
from my dad has told me,
you go out and Nova Scotia
on a trip and everyone pays,
you know,
for for a couple of day trips.
My God,
you were wrong.
You're ready for this 1.8 million.
Oh,
well fuck me running.
That's insane.
That's for a fish that and what did it
way depleted Bluefin tuna sold for one
point $8 million.
We didn't,
what does that mean?
It just means that they're there.
They're trying to get them endangered
because there are 500 pound,
a moderate size,
500 pound bluefin attentive and sold
for an unimaginable price of nearly 1.8
million US dollars.
A new record at a Tokyo fish auction.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay,
so that must be because the,
the supply is way down know.
Yeah,
it's it because that
those we need to stop.
I mean,
as much as I loved Bluefin Tuna,
we need to farm it and we
need to let it rebuild in the,
in the,
in the fucking,
if we ever want to fish it again because,
okay.
But hold on.
There's some fuckery here
at saint supposedly the high
prices paid at the annual
new year's.
Tuna's auction,
tuna auction in Tokyo
are a way to celebrate,
more likely is about publicity and
do not reflect actual market price.
Nevertheless,
the continued increasing price buyers
are paying for Bluefin tuna mirrors.
It's increasing rarity.
Okay,
so this is a really unusual
circumstance for this.
Probably fuckery.
Yeah,
they probably did that just so
people are paying attention.
Yeah.
There could be some crazy shit going on.
The old price was pretty
high anyway though.
The old record was $740,000.
Yeah.
Holy fucking shit.
And that wasn't even
supposedly fucked with that.
Supposedly a real record.
That's biggest.
Those things get,
I got to be a thousand pounds.
I think you gotta be okay.
Let's find out.
World record tuna.
I'm scared now.
I'm thinking of catching it.
Could you imagine you're just,
you're in for a fucking fights on
if he's gonna rip your arms off,
I mean,
that has a thousand
pound ball or whatever,
but however many pounds it is,
ball of muscle that just
wants to eat and I mean,
those things could eat us.
Biggest fish I ever caught was a Marlin,
Amanda.
It was not that big.
It was only about 70 pounds,
but it was,
my oldest daughter was a
vegetarian a little bit.
She's trying to be a vegetarian.
And I was,
uh,
you know,
she's just a kind person.
Yeah.
And at the time,
I think she's about probably 12,
if it makes sense.
Yeah.
About 12.
And I say,
you know what,
let's let's go fishing.
And I said,
we'll catch a fish,
we'll cook it,
will eat it and we'll understand sort
of the cycle of life because you know we
buy things in the supermarket and
we're very disconnected from it.
But you have to understand
like these animals,
they eat each other and this is like,
it's a natural way for people
to acquire food and its way.
People have done it throughout history,
but she tried to be like
this really kind person.
So it was a,
it was a moral reason.
Like she didn't want her to end.
Of course she loved animals.
So anyway,
we're fishing,
we fishing for maybe 15 minutes.
Yeah.
And I hook a Marlin maybe 15 minutes.
That's unheard of.
Like people fish for years
and they never catch a Marlin.
It's total stupid lock.
Yeah.
Cause there were trolling,
it's not like no skill whatsoever.
It just happened to hit my line.
So we get this mileage
jumping through the air.
It's wild man.
It's really cool.
It's not that big.
It's only like 70 pounds.
Yeah.
You know,
maybe.
Yeah,
I don't know how many feet long,
but it's about,
the guy said it was about 75 feet long.
They get hundreds thousand
over a thousand pounds.
Well this fucking thing,
they pull it,
they gaff it,
they bring it in the boat and then they
beat the fucking shit out of it with a
club.
And the way it works,
we were in Hawaii,
in Hawaii,
um,
the,
the owners of the boat,
they own the fish.
Like if you catch fish,
they'll take you and you'll enjoy it.
But it's also their livelihood.
It's how they make living.
So it's like,
it's a different sort of a
situation that a lot of charters,
it's like they,
they want you to have a good time and,
but we know you're in a resort and this
is our livelihood and we would like the
food too.
Is that cool?
And everybody's like,
yeah,
it's cool.
Cause otherwise like sometimes the food
would go to waste and that's terrible.
And I think they recognize that really
early and they put the Kabash on it and
they said,
look,
people are just trying to have some fun.
Let's have them have some fun,
catch the fish,
but we'll eat the fish.
So they were gonna take it and apparently
they bring it to a Luau and they
smoked the Moreland.
And my poor little 12 year
old is just sitting there.
And while this Marlin kitchen hope love,
and it's a big animal,
I mean it's in a boat with us and it's
a fairly big beautiful animal that once
you kill it,
the color goes away.
Yeah.
And it's the size of a dog.
It's like,
it's like a golden retriever size.
Wheaton it with clubs and it's,
it's real man.
Some real shit.
And when you're a 12 year old
girl wanted to be a vegetarian,
that's like,
that's a fucked up thing to say.
Yeah.
It didn't die right away either,
man.
It was flopping around,
they had ice on it and it did.
It was fine.
It wasn't moving at all.
And then I saw out of nowhere to fuck off,
off,
off.
It was devastating,
devastating.
And we didn't catch another fucking
thing for the rest of the trip.
We caught this one,
Marlin.
And then the rest of the day was just
looking down at this murder victim was in
the boat.
They're dead.
And then afterwards
taking photos together.
This is like really a
weird look on her face.
Those fucking murder victim
that we clubbed to death.
We didn't clubbed to death,
but we aided and abetted.
Yeah,
tricked it into the boat.
But they're uh,
apparently you can't eat Marlin.
Like I didn't know.
I didn't know you can't eat them,
but apparently you can.
What is the size of that one?
920 pound tuna caught last week.
Oh my God.
Look at that thing.
Oh,
I hope my dad's watching this.
What a fuck.
And they have to attach
it to a fucking crane,
ladies and gentlemen to
get it out of the water.
They hook it up to a crane.
I love Kimmy Fishman.
Killin fishes is a good time.
Well,
if you grew up near the ocean,
did it look at the size
of this fucking thing?
Oh my God,
that's a tuna.
That's incredible.
What a big animal.
Jesus.
I mean that thing you think of the speed,
those things get so big they die off
because they can't get enough food.
They just eat and eat and eat.
That's,
that's their whole life is spent hunting.
I mean,
they are like,
you know,
vicious.
What is the biggest one ever?
I have no idea.
Oh,
we've got to find out now because the
biggest two never caught it's gotta be
that one was what?
900 what it's gotta be
maybe 12 1300 pounds,
I would think.
Well,
let's see.
What's the world record tune await.
They're so cool looking to man.
Can you imagine if there was like tuna
that had four legs and when run down a
field looking like that?
Glistening and blue.
Just running like a bullet.
Fucking up every other animal
in his path at pack hunting.
Just eating lions and shits.
Managing of a fucking tuna could run
on ground as fast as it could swim.
That's frightening.
I,
yeah,
I always think of weird shit like that.
Like about the fucking,
what if parents were the size of,
and they walked off
for us like dogs and I,
I'm afraid of birds in general
cause they always hate me.
But you should be afraid of birds.
Birds are cunts.
Yeah.
And the evil man.
And they're vicious killers.
Yeah.
They fucking art man.
They're,
they're creepy.
The creepy animal.
Sorry.
You know,
they don't really give
a fuck about anything.
I mean they're,
they're in a real survival of
the fittest gene pool situation.
Yeah.
You know,
we're just lucky that
they're not that big.
He management birds like
the size of giraffes.
If Eagles like the size of the giraffes,
they would be eating people all day.
Nothing we could do to stop him.
We'd have,
we'd have to kill them all.
And it sounds like a
ridiculous thing to say.
Marriage in the world of two
and who could run the world?
Egos and size of drafts.
Well guess what asshole.
A giraffe's the size of a giraffe.
Okay.
There are animals that are that big.
We're just lucky they don't eat people.
Definitely.
We're lucky they're not against us.
We probably would've never got
to this place that they did.
I don't know where we're,
we're kinda tricky.
We've,
we've seem to Conaway this far.
I really don't think
it would have happened.
I think we,
we,
we came along like the premiere,
like boxes that became heavyweights
after Mike Tyson and lost his prime.
I like finding a gap.
We were like falling into
this like relaxed period.
My way through this.
Through evolution.
It was way easier to survive ourselves.
Dinosaurs got hit by that rock,
you know,
after buster Douglas came
along and he shrunk Tyson,
the world got a little safer.
You know,
back in those days I cried myself
to sleep and that happened.
It was a weird thing to see because
I watched it after the fact.
I didn't see the fight live.
I had heard what happened and I
still didn't believe it happened.
Now I was watching it.
I was like,
he's going to get up.
He's going to kick his ass.
That's my game.
My brother both literally cried.
I turned around,
I cried.
I like bawling to our parents.
Like,
why,
why?
Why did that happen?
I couldn't remember the last time I got
emotionally attached to a fight and I
was devastated when a fighter lost it
was Mike Mccallum when he knocked out
Donald Curry.
I was a big Donald Curry fan.
Donald Curry was the welterweight
champion at the time.
Donald McKinney,
I think he went up to one 54.
Donald Curry like ruined his career
because he kept cutting weight down to one
47.
Couldn't do it anymore.
He couldn't do it anymore.
He had um,
those fights with a,
not Macau,
but who was the other,
there was another like really strong,
well Twitter Cronk fighter from that
era and he'd knocked that dude out and
Donald Curry merge.
It's like the top pound for pound guy.
But then he fought Lloyd Huntington
and he was just too dehydrated.
He couldn't fucking do it anymore.
It just wasn't the same guy.
And everybody's like,
that's the top pound for pound fighter.
And that one beating to Lloyd Huntington,
never,
he never was the same again.
He went up to one 54 and then he
didn't have the physical advantages.
And you had it 47 and when you see
the UFC and you see like that this is,
especially in a higher way classes,
there's know big gaps,
huge.
And between the way classes,
what would you like it,
how would you,
if you,
if someone could like allow you to
create the optimum weight divisions,
what do you think it would be?
I mean,
she just don't want too many,
you know?
But I think there would be,
we would really figure out who
is pound for pound the best,
you know?
But at the same time,
maybe 10 pounds cause boxing,
there's so many champions he just gets,
it gets diluted.
You know,
in boxing is a sport in general is
a box that has a bunch of different
sanctioning buddies too.
That's where it gets really weird.
It's almost weird.
Are there?
Yeah.
Because of that than it is because
of the amount of weight classes.
Yeah.
Oh it's,
it's,
it's a,
all of it.
It's just all a cluster fuck,
you know?
Yeah.
People don't realize how many
weight classes there aren't boxing,
but it's crazy.
And they start at like one oh six right,
isn't it?
What's,
what's like light flyweight it's
to be something that's like it's,
I know I started like really light and
they go all the way up to one 95 and then
heavyweight and that's the deviation.
Like the USC the only gap they have.
It's more interesting as the
two oh five to two 65 yeah.
That's where they need to put at least
I think a weight class at two 40 or
something too.
And I think also in between 85
and two oh five it would be good.
I think have to tell you.
I could see that because you know,
just making every 10 pounds.
I think so too.
And I think that the big example of
that is between 55 and one 70 that's
especially as you get low in
percentage of body weight.
That's those,
those jumps,
the between that one and
the one 85 to light heavy.
Those are big jumps in
math.
15 pounds is a uh,
is a lot of person.
Yeah.
And it's also,
you're seeing these guys who are
making these cuts to get to two oh five
salaried guy like Jon Jones.
He's coming down from
like two 25 to 30 yeah,
like big shit at two oh five and if
you're like Kinda like don't want to cut
weight but you're really a
one 80 fiver and you find him,
you go,
Oh God no,
I got to lose the weight now.
Like you gotta you gotta
be realistic about this.
And especially because the
way the sport's evolved,
people get stuck in certain weight classes
because they're good for that weight
class and then they try and cut weight
or they try and gain weight and then they
end up not having the advantages
you know of of that they had,
they had before and they don't work
on it or they don't have it at all.
They just can't get it.
So then they ended up getting beat up by
someone smaller or something like that.
What is it like to be a part of this,
this sport right now for you?
Like as a top level professional fighter
because it's a really interesting time
as far as the sport,
like it's,
it's evolved to this point where there's,
there's clearly like the best athletes
that have ever been involved in MMA or
involved in and me now.
And the higher the level of fighting
and competition is as high as it's ever
been before.
Now how by far,
but you've had a chance to see it
from the outside for a long ass time.
Like what is,
what is it like for you now,
you know,
the evolution of,
of the,
the people of the fighters.
I think as a,
as a country,
I think we're getting pussified,
you know,
kids aren't allowed to get in fist fights.
I think it's a rite of passage for
young men to get in fist fights,
you know,
and not jumping each other.
I'm talking no weapons,
just,
you know,
just Duke it out and
deal with your problems.
Some people don't want to do that though.
And they don't want to be
harassed by people who want to be,
if they don't want it,
they don't want to do.
They shouldn't have to.
Right.
But how do you stop that though?
The exactly.
I Dunno,
it's,
but that's not been just saying,
but we're,
we're building better athletes in the gym,
but we have to now.
Now I,
which I,
I,
I get as a good thing.
We,
if we want to build a tough kid,
if we want to make him tough,
we'll blow them in the gym.
And that maybe you know that that is a
good thing because not only is he going
to be tough,
but he's not going to be a
dick like I used to be know.
Because like I said,
I started out beating up bullies and
then I ended up just being a bully.
You know?
I'm glad you're really honest about that,
man.
I think that's really
important because I think,
you know,
there's a lot of kids out there that
are fighting that watch guy like you and
look up to you and when maybe they might
be on a similar path and they hear that
and they can learn from your mistakes.
Yeah,
I've made just about
every mistake that it is,
you know,
whether it's that or Diana Diana of drugs,
drug overdose or whatever or whatever.
I've done a lot of things and it's just,
it's,
there's so many things that
I feel like I can share.
Um,
and it do,
I can help one person change.
That'll be,
that'll work.
You know,
little,
obviously I'd like to
help as many as possible,
but um,
you know,
just try and,
especially with the people
that are closest to me,
like we've got some amateur
guys that I'm trying to,
trying to just turn into super
athletes and they already are,
but just get them focused and
ready and not make any mistakes.
It's very difficult for a
fighter to transition
from being a fighter too,
like mainstream life to going back to
being like a regular person with a regular
job who you know doesn't have those
big crazy thrills every few months.
You know,
you just have sort of like
this weird steady drip of of,
of life juice instead of
this wild rollercoaster rush
that everybody knows you
can only stay on for so long.
Yeah,
but the thing that I always try to stress
with people is that like one of the
best things about martial arts is the
development of the ability to do something
good,
to be good at something and know what
it's like to be good at something.
And then from there,
like you knew how hard it was to get good.
You didn't start out good,
you started out Shitty,
but you got better and he
got better and you get that.
That understanding of that is,
it's so important for everything.
Don't look at like the finish line and go,
I'm never going to get there.
Look at progress and you can get anywhere
as long as there's not some crazy
physical limitation.
Yeah.
That,
that's,
that's what I tell people,
cause they always turn
to me for rehab stories,
you know,
the drunk stories or whatever.
Cause I had been to
two rehabs and whatnot.
How old are you?
29.
How old were you when you
went through your first rehab?
I was 19,
I think.
Wow.
What was it for?
Um,
I got caught with,
with some pills and then,
uh,
I was appeal guy.
Um,
and then it was just through the court.
I had to check in and I got kicked out
of some like class things and they,
and they put me in like,
uh,
outpatient rehab program.
And then I ended up,
um,
the second one was,
you know,
before in between WBC and tachy when I,
became world champ.
Um,
I got in trouble,
you know,
got arrested,
was looking at probably going to prison
for like three to five for just doing
some dumb shit.
And then I had,
I had a record,
so me doing anything bad
but put me in prison.
So I checked myself into
Rehab and they were like,
oh good job,
little buddy.
And they'll pat on the head,
you can stay there for six months.
And it was live in and,
and at first it was just escape,
just to scapegoat for
me not to go to prison.
But then it actually helps,
you know,
the people there helped me.
They'll program helped
me to actually getting,
getting my,
uh,
just to just help me get my life
together and I had to be sober,
you know?
And I stayed sober for a long time,
you know,
and it was,
it was,
it was good for me,
you know,
it did.
I,
it actually gave me some perspective on
life because I was just such a mess for
so long.
But isn't it
crazy to be a guy who is such a Masson's
a wild and with like this really self
destructive style of living,
especially with,
with regards to drugs and your body,
but you're a professional.
Lastly,
a high level professional athletes.
How it works for so long.
Yeah.
How the fuck did it work for so long?
Um,
I,
I don't know really.
I mean I'm,
I'm like a cockroach or something.
There's something,
something,
there's something inherently,
I don't know if it's right or wrong.
I hope nobody tries to imitate it.
Yeah.
Do not,
do not do what I've done.
They'll learn,
learn from that.
Don't do that.
I'm a walking mistake.
Go to the gym,
Bitch.
Exactly.
The gym first.
If I would have spent those extra,
I mean hours that I was doing stupid
things.
I believe me,
I've,
I've done calculations to
everything I could have put in that,
that cause they say it's 10,000
hours to master something,
you know?
Right.
So I could have put an extra 10,000 hours
into Jiu Jitsu and extra 10,000 and to
kickboxing and extra
10,000 and the wrestling.
If I would've done that because
I've been training for that long,
I could have fit that in there.
I would be,
I would make everyone else look silly.
Well don't you think though
that the something about
you that is the way you are
because of the adversity
that you've gone through?
Oh,
of course I wouldn't change a thing.
I'm just saying that right,
but isn't that weird?
You know,
I just like,
I would be the motherfucker.
Motherfucker thought I'd be a choir boy.
Crazy from that cause I
wasn't doing anything nuts.
Yeah,
I would.
Yeah.
And then,
and then this,
then this,
this piece would show up now and it
would just blow it all that happens.
So a lot of guys too,
right?
They,
they get it instead of on the way up.
They get it.
Once they get up,
get there and they're like,
oh,
this is too much fun.
It never given you money.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those dudes out there
like they should've never given you
money.
Especially crazy wild,
impulsive athletes and fighters
like the Tyson stories.
So the most,
the dude got tigers,
he had his own talkers.
He was like the most legendary
stories of spending money.
$200 million.
Where did it go?
Seen his show that he does that.
No,
he's a stand up show.
His one man show.
I heard it.
I heard it's awesome.
I heard it's incredible.
I want to,
I really want to,
Dana white called me up after he goes,
dude,
it's one of the greatest things
I've ever seen in my life.
He goes,
it's fucking amazing.
Spike Lee,
I guess direct it.
Is that what happened?
And they just,
they put it together.
It's a fucking show,
you know?
And it's just him,
isn't it?
Yeah.
He puts up a number.
It's with,
it's 200 or $300 million,
puts up a number on the thing and
it's like this giant screen and goes,
that's how my time lost
$300 million or 200 million or whatever.
There was 100 million,
whatever.
So same amount of money.
You just spent it?
Yeah.
He just spent it
and crashed it and then
gave it to the cop.
Yeah,
like tainted if it's all scratched up.
I was like,
not interested.
This thing's a piece of shit now.
I really want it.
There you have it and it cost
me a hundred grand to fix.
He used to wear furs and shit.
He used to walk around
like Jack Dempsey style,
like with the hat,
like Jack Johnson when Jack Johnson was
the heavyweight champion was hanging out
with all these white chicks.
Nobody did it.
They were trying to make those laws so
he could just state people don't even
know if you ever seen,
was it unforgivable blackness?
Is that what the documentary is called?
What is the documentary called?
I need to quote it because
it's an amazing documentary.
I'll just blackness.
Jack Johnson.
Boy,
am I going to jail for
fucking do a Google search?
I'm my show.
Yeah,
I don't,
um,
I don't remember who made it.
I want to say it was Ken Burns.
Okay.
Cause you know,
he does a lot of those
unforgivable blackness.
That's what it's called.
MMM.
Is it Ken Burns?
I don't know if I saw
it as Ken Burns movie,
but I saw it read pretty recently.
Oh,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
It's incredible.
I mean you've got,
people don't realize what a bad mother
fucker this guy was and what incredible
racism he encountered,
like the racism that fighter's encountered
today or people encountered today.
Like here's a perfect example,
the recent thing with Oprah Winfrey,
do you know about this thing?
No,
it's,
you know,
they shouldn't have done it.
She went to a store in
Switzerland or some shit.
Is that where it was?
And um,
she,
there was a purse,
it was a very expensive purse and she
asked to see it and the store clerks said,
oh,
you can't afford that purse.
You don't only want to
look at it like we should.
You should look at something less money.
And Roper was like,
Oh shit.
Really?
Okay.
That's the kind of racism that Oprah has
to experience in 2013 with Jack Johnson
experiences.
Like it's like to these people,
it's like they wanted him dead.
And slavery had just ended
like inside of their lifetime,
1865.
So you're dealing with just a few decades
later and all of a sudden there's this
dude just knockin white dudes senseless
and taking these white chicks.
And impaling them on
this fucking Super Dick,
the likes of which white women had
never seen before and they were just
following them around,
a fallen out of his car while
he's driving down the street.
I mean,
he had,
he was like the first black I ever with
dope cars that get across that border
and just kill it.
And he just did it like,
fuck you.
What are you going to do?
He would take them across state lines.
They try to get them
for all kinds of shit.
Transporting white women and
across dirt lines that they drew.
Who government was after you for
sleeping with white women that you're,
you're waiting sir.
Sad,
sad movie.
And then at the end
when he throws a fight,
you know,
you could tell he throws a fight.
Was it?
No,
it wasn't just Willard.
Who was it that he froze?
I don't remember.
But,
uh,
I don't want to tell you.
In fact,
even if I did remember,
you should watch it.
Go get it.
So it's an amazing
documentary and it's just,
we see like,
like those old Jack Johnson fights or um,
you see Jack Dempsey's old fights.
Like,
boy,
you're dealing with a totally
different kind of human being.
Back then it was a lot different.
There were animals,
they,
they're there.
I think we're slowly losing that,
that,
that piece of us,
you know,
with whatever,
whatever is it,
that's everything.
Everything is taking it away from us,
but we're slowly losing
that killer instinct.
Well,
you know,
it's funny that Tyson latched
on to the Jack Dempsey.
Jack Dempsey was like one of his like
main heroes and his main idols for that
style of fighting that just
ferocious mauling style,
you know,
and Tyson sort of recognize
that he was a throwback.
I mean,
you think about that in the 80s and then
you look at like Jack Dempsey was doing
it when there was no TVs.
No,
they find out about fights from the radio
and he was doing that exact thing that
long ago.
You were either they're in person
or you were listening to guys talk.
Jack Dempsey.
When I left Jack Dempsey,
he's down.
I mean,
I guess,
yeah,
I guess it was,
it was all word of mouth,
you know,
it was all back then the handover in.
Did you see that a photo that somebody
posted on the underground the other day
of a fight from a 1913.
Did you see that shit?
I don't think so.
With MMA or do you know that you find it?
Do you know what it's on my Instagram.
If you go to my Instagram,
um,
it's a,
a dude name,
Irish Rati.
Um,
it's a boxing match and
it's a boxing match from,
you know,
1913 that they've turned into a,
a a color image.
They've processed it yet and,
and,
and made it a true to life.
It's fucking incredible.
Pull it up here for you.
Look at this shit.
Look at that picture.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Holy Shit is right.
It's incredible to have those guys.
That was back when they used to
fight like 50 fucking rounds.
Yeah,
right.
I mean,
didn't they have like some
crazy fights back then?
Were they?
What was the most amount of rounds you
think anybody ever fought back in those
days?
I probably 50 or 60 I mean,
those guys look like they're like on the
verge of beating each other to death.
Very close.
Very,
but I've seen some UFC fights.
It looked like that to
Joe Stevenson and Bj Penn.
The end of that fight,
it looked like Joseph
Stevenson got murdered.
Yes.
You know,
I mean,
well especially those forehead cuts,
forehead cuts are responsible
for some of the craziest,
most ridiculous scenes
in the octagon ever.
But what did,
what did that big foot
Silva's manager say his,
his head is well irrigated.
It's just the wording.
Giant Noggin.
Yeah,
no shit.
That was a crazy one.
Longest boxing match ever.
Let's find out
ever poem.
Good at typing
was the longest boxing match in history.
Oh my God.
A boxing match land.
It lasted seven hours.
How many I can do the math.
What is that?
Is that real?
Oh my God.
Listen to this.
The longest boxing match ever took place
in New Orleans on April six of 1893 the
matches between Andy Bowen and Jack Burke,
both of whom claimed the lightweight
title after the reigning Champ,
Jack McCall full all a fee,
all of fee check my call if he retired,
the winner of this take all purse was
set at $2,500 and in order to decide who
is really the new champion,
the match was set to fought to a finish.
They fought to a finish.
I like that.
All through the contest,
fighters went at each other aggressively
pounding each other with their gloves,
inflicting and sustaining
tremendous punishment that red,
like someone wrote it
with their pants off.
That red light is vigorous.
They masturbating hold up and shaved
and yet three minute rounds wore off.
Oh my God.
They went to 111 rounds.
Both fighters,
dazed and weary,
gave up and did not come
out of their corner pools.
Well,
you can't fight 112 well,
more raw.
That'd be one guy telling him,
just get up rocky and your win.
All that.
What's that?
Guinness says it's 276 rounds in 1825
but that's English people lying might,
we're not much longer than that.
Our insurance is superior.
We've proper boxing training.
That sounded more South African,
so maybe that right man,
I dunno.
Whoever fought over a hundred rounds.
It's the craziest fucking
human being that's ever lived.
That fight.
It was only four and a half hours.
Oh,
that's weird.
What do they have like 32nd rounds?
It doesn't even make sense.
I can't even do the math.
I don't know.
I'm not going to try 2,500 bucks.
That's crazy.
I wonder where the welter for the
welterweight championship of the world are
lightweight round these days.
It's a good question.
It's a very good question.
I bet it'd be like 1 million bucks.
Yeah.
Is that weird?
Like when when you hear about
like economies imploding
and then all of a sudden
like a loaf of bread's worth $1 million,
like how the fuck,
what does that even mean?
Yeah.
I don't even understand that
people have billions of dike.
How does that number even
a real number and can I,
how do you pull out $1 billion in cash?
Let me see.
Yeah.
At a certain point in time,
you have to admit the hack the game.
Okay.
You hack the game somehow.
Dude,
how'd you get $10 billion
that I don't understand.
When you know your guy like Bill Gates,
you have submarine inside your giant.
Hey,
what happened here?
What exactly did you do?
Where are you getting all that money?
This isn't fair.
Escape.
Pause in your house,
jettison you to the middle of the fucking
ocean whenever it fucking dangerous
shows up.
Yeah.
You have a constant team of
security detail around you
that's like having a bank
around you all the time.
Bill Gates is worth what?
100 billion or something crazy like that.
It would if it was the whole Jv,
him dropping $40,000 he shouldn't
pick it up kind of thing.
Yeah,
that's what they say.
It's like if he drops $40,000 it's worth
more of his time to keep moving forward
than it is to turn around and pick it up.
He just,
what happened was he just didn't
turn around to pick up the bonus.
I just got almost for,
for bludgeoning and
other man for 15 minutes.
He,
if he dropped that,
he wouldn't pick it up.
It is crazy.
If you think about how
much more difficult MMA is.
Yeah.
Then almost every other job
that you have to do physically,
like besides being a soldier
or a cop or a fireman,
where you're really putting your life in
danger on a daily basis with fires and
bullets.
Take all those out.
And then ambulance driver
pre fucking dangerous.
There's a few race car drivers,
dangerous as shit,
but MMA fighters of fucking scary one.
That's,
that's one of the most dangerous jobs you
can have other than like crab fishing,
those fucking crazy assholes.
Deadliest catch guys guys.
There's guys are nuts.
They're,
they're secluded out there for a reason.
You friends with Quida?
Uh,
I'm,
we don't talk to anybody.
He's a cool dude.
That's a great guy.
Click.
Greta did that shit for like a year.
I went to like test is metal,
the mountain.
It was a fucking crabber crazy fuck.
He's the kind of guy who would just pick
that sounds fun or you make some cash.
Cool.
Okay.
I gotta go.
Yeah,
yeah.
Stop moving.
Yeah.
That dude's got some endurance just
on the boat the whole time doing that.
I've seen him blow off
more energy at a way in.
Then I have from a real workout,
like a real workout.
Like today I'm going to have some coffee.
I'm gonna really work out.
Meanwhile,
he gets more cardio in on the way up to
the scale and he's always fucking like
super energetic where
everybody else is dried out.
You know,
they're,
they're cutting weight and Guido
wasn't much bigger than one 55 he had,
he has ridiculous endurance.
Yeah.
That he's,
he's just,
that's one of those natural things that,
uh,
he's never at rest anyways,
not just,
it's constant.
It's,
his rest is active.
She's never going to get tired.
It's a great fucking guy to guy.
Very,
very fun dude to hang out with.
And he drives like,
he fights.
Do you ever drive with him?
He's awesome.
He drags you like,
all right,
clay,
Galena.
Close my eyes and just hold on.
Fucking Chicago savages.
Yeah.
It's different than what it is.
Those Illinois people or animals,
Bro,
never been that cold as fuck.
It's just those cities where it's
really cold and there's a lot of people,
it takes a hardy mother fucker
to rise above and those spots.
Yeah,
I wouldn't last eaten alive.
You're a like a growing up here,
you grew up in paradise.
This is the greatest weather
in the history of the universe.
Yeah,
it's great.
But you've missed that adversity that
you get from dealing with the weather.
Yeah,
there's like a knowledge that
it's out there that we don't have.
We're like oblivious out here.
Yeah,
I like that.
Sonny,
another day,
you know,
my,
my Stepdad for,
for instance,
world down hunter and tracker like
sad and he's almost 80 years old.
He's this mountain of a man
was in the CIA and he's out,
he's a mason and he's
just this like that guy.
My mom met him,
you know,
being a chef at his wilderness
hunting lodge in the middle of BFE in,
in Alaska.
Like the Guy I've seen pictures
of him with with polar bear,
he killed like,
oh,
it's just this big
mountain and polar bear.
Holy Shit,
I actually have a polar bear rug.
It's not have a house to put it in yet.
But,
but I mean it's just,
it that's like that
guys is just weathered.
Like he don't eat polar bear.
Yeah.
D I don't think so.
I think he just just did it to do,
but at the back then
he's said guys almost 80.
So back then it was okay.
I mean he doesn't hunt anymore.
Then we own black people,
which shot polar bears,
whatever.
Don't worry about it.
It's okay.
We drove drunk shooting in polar
bears out the window of the car.
Yeah,
you're,
you're supposed to hunt certain
Predator Bairstow though.
They have to keep their numbers down.
People don't like that,
that idea.
But it does become a real
problem when you have,
um,
there's like the,
the game wardens in these areas and
the department of fish and game.
Yeah.
They're very meticulous about keeping
track of numbers of both animals that are
pray like dear.
And then animals that are,
uh,
there are also predators like
cats and bears and shit like that.
And they're pretty good at figuring
out how to manage that stuff.
But you have to kill some of them,
unfortunately.
Yeah,
I understand that people hate that
idea because they're so beautiful and
majestic,
but the reality of biology is that there
has to be a certain balance of Predator
and prey because if there's not,
then we become a danger.
They're going to come fuck us.
And nobody likes that idea.
People,
people that are like,
especially like people were
animal rights people or you know,
people love animals.
There's a lot of people that their dogs
are like their best fucking friends.
The only thing that they
can count on for love,
you know what I mean?
That's not even a bad thing.
Not a bad thing.
It's true.
So I understand where they're coming from.
Like you would think about the a bear.
It's just like a big dog,
but this is a big dog.
They will eat your asshole.
All right.
The thing doesn't give a shit about you.
Exactly.
Without even it.
It wants to eat.
Yeah.
It's a heartless monster and for
the most part they're harmless.
You don't go near them.
You stay away from them for the most part.
You're right.
We're going to be fine.
But the reality is when they get to a
certain number and they start taking down
elk in front of people at the camp site
and scaring the shit out of everybody.
Yeah.
You ever see a 12 foot
bear take out a moose?
I haven't either,
but just I'm trying to get,
here is a video of a bear in a,
I've never forgot this.
Pull this shit up,
Jamie.
It's a bear.
Eats a moose in a driveway,
dude.
Okay,
just dude.
Imagine.
Imagine you're living in Alaska.
Okay.
I'm five eight.
I stood next to a moose
and it's fucking huge.
It's Dick was over my head.
They're gigantic.
I went to Alaska.
I was a kid.
That place is fucking
beautiful and they're gigantic.
I mean,
I didn't,
I didn't get really close enough to him.
It was to get his stick over my head.
But look at this,
but this Mousse,
which is gigantic,
okay,
is killed by a grizzly bear and
this guy's fucking driveway.
So could you imagine
there's a thing that's,
oh,
you know,
whatever.
10 times his size of a deer and it
gets killed by a giant wild dog.
That's essentially what a bear is.
A giant bulletproof
wild dog Moose or what?
Like 12 feet tall.
Yeah.
Fucking huge.
It's a huge animal.
That's not the biggest moose in the world.
No,
but it's a,
and it's a female.
It's a big fucking animal.
And what's really crazy about
bear is bear eat moose alive.
They'd all the animals,
they kill alive.
A lot of times they go guts first.
They don't even bother killing the animal.
They just start eating them.
You look at the size
of that fucking thing,
just ripping chunks off of this Moose.
He's eating the guts now.
That's what they go for the first.
But they're,
they're just,
they're everywhere up there.
And it comes a time where the,
uh,
the wildlife people determine that,
okay,
are the population is too high?
And so we have to manage this.
What does that with a dragged it away.
Wow.
Look how they dragged it away.
Look at the size of it.
Back that up so it puts it in perspective.
Oh my God.
Look at them dragging it away.
Look how big it is.
You don't realize how big it is
because the bear is so fucking big,
but when they drag it away,
you're like,
Holy Shit.
How big is that bear?
Now let's go back to the bear.
Go back to the bear.
Look how big the Paris.
God Damn.
How big is that fucking bear?
Oh,
that's big bear dude.
Literally a fucking 600 pound angry dog
with bigger claws and look at the size
of that thing.
Now that you know how big that fucking
moose is in comparison to a car,
that bear is huge.
Oh
God.
Damn.
Fuck living in Alaska.
My mom was saying when she went to go
hunter dall sheep that of course my
Stepdad's not going to tell her,
but a bear a bear.
It was tracking them the whole time.
No,
of course.
Yeah,
they told the whole time and like,
and like,
she's like,
oh we're wading through like thick,
you know,
brush shit and just,
I wonder why.
Just her telling the story.
I was like,
man,
that's fucking frightening
having something.
If something wants to eat you,
it's so crazy because you can get there
at the wrong place and the wrong time
and you can get there when there's an
old bear that can't catch catch moose or
deer anymore and they have worn out
teeth and they see you and they're like,
oh I can catch you.
And then they just eat you.
And especially when
it's late in the season,
they say that's when it
gets really desperado.
Bears will eat their cubs and they get
really desperate because there's no food.
It can't catch any fish.
They can't.
There's no salmon laughed and
they're starving to death.
And so they'll fucking eat
everything in front of them.
You can catch them in that really intense
desperation cause they're the last
animals that haven't hibernated the
healthy fat bears that what a grizzly man
man,
that moves.
Yes.
I talk about that every week.
You can't talk about it
anymore unfortunately.
Let's talk about that.
I'm just saying that it was,
it was like that.
That was exact storyline.
Yeah.
The guys stayed way too long.
He was there in October or November or
some shit like that when they're supposed
to already be sleeping.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing,
man.
To live in the presence
of those crazy beasts.
My favorite shows are all these
subsistence shows like Alaska,
the last frontier.
It's my,
one of my favorite shows.
I get giddy like a little
schoolgirl when I shits on.
I got to watch it and it's
these people they live,
that's a bunch of families.
The Kitchener family and
I believe like jewel,
you know that a beautiful
singer and incredible voice.
She is like related to these people.
Fascinating.
But these folks live in like a really
remote part of Alaska and they have a
homestead with eight.
They're responsible for everything.
They're responsible for all their
own repairs on their equipment.
They get all their own meat from either
cows that they have to butcher cause
they run cattle or animals that they hunt.
Whether they hunt bear or a moose and
they have like very specific chores they
do and they have maybe four or five
months a year where they're just trying to
keep it together and then it's bundled
up for the cold and their whole life is
about preparing for the cold.
Yeah.
And they're just fucking storing
fish and every is just a mad dash.
Getting up at six pulling nets of fishing,
freezing.
I'm smoking them.
Everybody's working around clock and
then shoot the fucking frost comes in.
The river freezes over the point
where you drive cars on it.
Yeah,
it's gangster cold up there
and we get to watch that.
It's amazing.
I'm a Dork for it,
dude.
Well My,
I,
my,
you know,
my mom went through it.
Your mom went through it because she was
living in being the chef at the hunting
lodge.
God Damn.
In middle of nowhere.
I mean,
you know,
she was living in Alaska for
a while and obviously Jim's,
you know,
I'm sure listening to this,
he's,
you know,
he's old,
but yeah,
he was up there forever.
Wow.
That's harsh climates or I don't,
I like southern California
with way too much.
There's something amazing about the
people that come from those spots though.
They have a different,
does a different sort of like
mentality that they possess.
It's for a pussy like me.
It's a so attractive.
So you know this,
this guy that's a man right there,
doesn't have a bank account.
He's got some beaver skins.
He's going to trade for gasoline for
his fucking snowmobile and he's driving
around where it's 80 below zero and he's
running traps and that's how he feeds
his kids.
Yes guy.
There's a fucking show called mountain
men with this guy takes up plane every
winter.
He flies,
he leaves his family behind.
He flies for months and
camps out in the woods.
He's got like these shacks up there and
he runs these trap lines and just kills
animals in the wintertime.
It's like apparently easier to kill him
cause they're desperado and they go and
find the bait and snap down on it.
And this guy just takes it all and
freezes them and skins and then brings him
back home.
It'd be lives out there by himself
for months and months at a time.
No phone,
no nothing.
Just a wood house.
Woodhouse in a snowmobile.
Jesus and it.
Yeah,
and this party,
that's thing I look,
you'll do it and could you do it?
I don't know.
I guess you could if you had to,
like if that was your life,
if there was no way around it,
if there's like,
listen,
um,
you know,
they came to you and said,
hey,
uh,
there's a fucking,
there was an ice age comment.
There's nothing we can do about it.
Figured that we're going
to have to figure it out.
We're going to have to about four months
out of the year to gather up food and
then it's going to be 80 below zero
by the time December comes around.
I can,
I do.
Okay.
I do it.
Well,
those people are going to die
off because you know what?
People are doing that in Anchorage.
Go Up there,
go to Fairbank's.
Yeah,
go up there.
There's a whole city,
the whole city where it gets so cold that
you could freeze to death while you go
to get your mail.
Jesus Christ,
you can freeze to death.
They all carry candles
in their car and shit.
If you get trapped somewhere,
you've got to light a candle.
You can't just sit in your car,
you'll freeze to death to him.
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
That's,
that's not even,
I mean like I,
I'm,
I would love to,
I want to learn to bow hunt
and go kill and eat my food,
but I definitely want to come
home and bring it home to my mind.
Might be air conditioned house by the
beach or the breeze and you know the Nice,
yeah.
Did your dad take you on,
on like hunts and fishing
trips and stuff like that?
He came into my life,
my,
my Stepdad,
the hunter,
um,
later on where,
I mean I would love,
I,
that's my goal is to now eventually
take him on like one last hunt,
you know,
cause he's the man bulletproof.
But you know,
cause he doesn't hunt anymore.
I want want to go up to Alaska and,
and,
and I don't want to kill
anything like a bear,
anything.
I want to kill him.
I'm just gonna eat like elk Caribou,
Caribou,
Caribou gets them a dall sheep,
you know.
But some of the difficult,
but my dad had the side,
we were food fit was just how fishing.
So we're always hunting something.
Right,
right,
right.
And it's,
it's,
it's definitely,
I love doing it.
I love,
I knew I'd also need to go fishing again.
Do you feel like the,
that's a primal thing too,
that almost,
I mean,
not obviously on the
same level as fighting,
but there's something about like the
satisfaction that you get from acquiring
your own food is a very primal thing.
It's the most intimate thing you can
share with another creature is taking its
life sound like a fucking psycho.
If I was the fucking FBI profiler,
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm going to follow your
Twitter from here on out,
pal.
Why?
It's true cause you,
you get to send it out.
I'm not,
you just get the kit.
He had to kill something and eat it.
No,
I know.
I'm fucking with you.
Obviously we're joking around,
but um,
I know what you mean.
I killed a deer for the
first time in my life,
lasts a winter and uh,
it was a very intimate feeling when
you're eating the liver of an animal that
you just shot a couple hours ago.
It's weird.
He's fucking delicious.
Unbelievably delicious.
And the reality is it's the most ethical
way to approach it because that animal
is probably not going to
survive much longer anyway.
It gets unfucking believable.
He cold in Montana in the winter and
a lot of them just freeze to death.
There's a fucked up picture.
Jamie be seen this shit of a,
an elk frozen to death standing up.
Yeah.
You want to know how brutal Colorado gets?
Bitch,
check this shit out.
There's an elk that they
found that froze to death,
like trying to cross a lake
or something like that,
just like standing up frozen.
It was a trying to how whatever wasn't
really tall snow and it's stuck standing
up and animals have eaten
big chunks off of it.
So it is like this freaky carcass of
this standing up Zombie elk that's a,
that has like these chunks
taking it out of its body,
but it's frozen standing up.
Oh Man.
You find it.
How dare you.
That's how you got it.
Let me see it.
This is going to freak out.
I'm sure there's people that
have some more MMA questions.
You're gonna fucking stop.
Talk about animals.
Totally.
When they remember you fucking queer.
Hey,
don't be mean.
You hate her.
Folks.
Look at this.
Look at that fucking elk.
Dude.
Are you shitting me?
Can you see it in that picture?
Is there a better picture?
That's gotta be a better
picture than that man.
See if he can find the,
the actual picture,
because the actual picture of the
high rise picture is fucking crazy.
This thing's frozen standing up
and big chunks or bitten off of it.
That's fucked up.
My point is we're such
pussies here in California.
It's true.
It is true.
I comes to the weather.
Yeah,
we can't.
Exactly.
But,
um,
on the other hand,
it's a,
it's a great place to develop
your free or an MMA fighter.
I mean,
look at it.
There's a picture.
Holy Shit that's even
crazier than it looked.
I mean,
they're,
they,
they're eating whole straight it.
Yeah.
It's just the body.
Like you could see the spine and the
organs are all missing in the top area by
the spine.
And the organs are all like chew dancer.
Of course.
Yes,
of course.
It's delicious.
They get right to it.
What you gonna do,
bitch,
they probably ate the
asshole before it even died.
Like,
Oh shit.
What we got and he has harp.
I'm a bear.
Actually.
It was a bear.
There'd be nothing that has to be
probably a coyotes or something like that.
Cause they didn't even knock it over or
chew through the bone wolves that are
probably chewed right through the,
what am I,
a wildlife expert?
Listen to me.
Like I'm a fucking,
like,
I'm the crocodile hunter.
Zoologists to some shit that fucks on.
So,
uh,
let me ask you about some,
some upcoming fights,
people that people always request
this and I never get around to it.
Um,
when,
um,
when fighters are on,
to talk about upcoming cards because
there's a bunch of like really interesting
fights coming up that
people are interested in.
First of all,
I got to ask you,
uh,
what do you think about
Anderson and Chris Weidman,
the rematch that fight?
I think this time,
uh,
obviously Chris,
you know,
can beat him I think,
but I don't think he's going to,
I think I think Anderson is going
to blast through them quick.
I really,
I saw a turn in that
second round where I just,
I thought that the tie,
they completely turned and Anderson does
the same thing he always does and it's
one to dip,
you know,
he just,
because it's MMA guys don't
know how to box very well.
It's just a straight basic one,
two,
right.
And he always goes the same way.
One,
two.
And then if you start to pressure him,
he goes back and dips
to that cause that side.
It's the same watch other video.
It's what he does.
Uh,
you know,
and I don't know why mine
have not even known it,
but all he did was take one step.
I met Ray Longo knew it.
All he did was,
you know,
flash,
he kind of stepped into South Bulb,
flashed out of jab and then
through the hook and it was ugly.
It wasn't,
it wasn't beautiful textbook punching,
but it worked
well.
You know,
that's that same hook that he
knocked your hall out with.
He has a weird long hook where he is this
arm like fully extended and he catches
you on the end with like his hand turned.
Exactly.
And then,
and,
and Anderson's used to being out here.
Yeah.
You know,
and he already got
crack coming in.
So it's a,
he ate mean he just got lazy to come
overconfident or whatever it was.
And,
but I think that he,
I would love to see him in blitz Weidman.
I just,
because I want to see Anderson do
it to somebody because he does it so
beautifully.
And then nothing against
Chris.
Right.
I know what you're saying.
He's the most beautiful guy to
watch as far as movement by far.
Yeah.
He's um,
it's hard to wrap your head around that.
He could like a guy like Chris Weidman
and want to see him get fucked up.
People don't understand that.
It's not what it is.
It's just you want to see the performance.
Exactly.
I want to see,
I want to see a beautiful performance and,
and no one makes it more beautiful than
Anderson and when it's against a really
tough guy,
it makes it performance
all the more spectacular.
Exactly.
I'm a huge rich Franklin fan.
I've always been a rich Franklin
fan and he's a great guy.
He was a great champion.
Yeah.
So when beat Franklin for the title,
I knew how fucking tough rich Franklin is.
Yeah.
So it made it all the more crazy.
When you're watching that
you're like Jesus Christ.
Like,
if you don't know how tough Lee Marie is,
if you don't know how toughly Marius,
watch Lee Marie versus Anderson
Silva Watch first of all,
watch lean Murray versus a host of other
motherfuckers that he just slept with
like one punch,
like a mere renova already slept him.
He was a sniper.
He hit a piston of a right
hand and he's that guy.
Different breed,
that gap psychopath.
Well he's in jail right now.
Listen to this podcast.
He listens to the pockets of Morocco.
Yes.
I think he's still in Morocco.
I probably living in the castle,
they probably got like a little
man hole in his gym and his uh,
his cage rather.
And like when Smith,
the guards go to bread.
Yeah,
he went and got a girl pregnant
while he's in the cage in prison.
He probably has like a little man hall
and he opens it up and it's like fucking
Saddam Hussein's palace
underneath the gym.
It's,
he's a crazy criminal character,
but he was an excellent fighter.
His Day.
It very dangerous striker and Anderson
Silva just ran it on him and the way he
attacked him so systematically his legs
out from under him and Anderson just
fought brilliantly and also
showed a fucking worldclass chin.
Yeah,
know,
which is interesting because this is the
first time we've really seen Anderson
staggered and hurt and stopped.
It's never happened before and it's,
it's,
it's such a cliche.
It's the shot you didn't expect.
Exactly.
So cliche,
but even on a great fighter like Anderson,
I mean even on a great
fighter like Anderson,
it's so hard to believe,
but it's a shot that you didn't expect.
Yeah.
And perfectly landed point
of the Chin Rep legs go,
that's it.
Lights are amazing,
but it's also,
I think in a way it's poetic that
he's the guy who got caught that way.
Yeah.
Because as much as I'm a huge Anderson
Silva Fan and I will never not be the guy
who was like a human
highlight real of excellence.
That's how I would describe
Anderson Silva's career,
just infection perfection.
But it's good for young guys to see.
It's good for young guys come up to go,
okay,
that can happen.
Even to that guy.
You can't do that.
That can happen either.
But you can do that though.
Sometimes.
You can do it only out.
Only for so long.
Yeah,
we're there with depends on who you're
fighting to and what's the circumstance.
You know?
You know what,
fine.
I'm looking forward to,
man.
It's fucking to this weekend.
You're Riaa Hall and John Dooms Day,
Howard.
Uh,
they're going to slug it out,
going to beat the crap out of each other.
That's kind of people who don't know.
If you don't remember
John Howard and you know,
you seen her ride Uriah hall from tough,
who would just had some of the most
wicked knockouts in the history of the
fucking competition.
The ultimate fighter is like the,
the,
the highlight reel of ultimate fighter.
Without a doubt at the tops arrival hall.
Oh,
by far,
without a doubt.
That wheel kick k that the right
hand to make it into the finals.
I mean,
he's a fucking monster,
man.
He is really tough.
His striking is so,
but you know who throws
fucking hammers dooms day.
John Howard,
a good Yammer,
tie striker.
He's real good able to
do that and I think it's,
Oh man,
that's it.
That's a tough call.
I'm going to have to go
with your idea I think,
but I mean if anyone's going
to end up spoiling that party,
it's going to be Howard.
Well you know Howard is
also only like five seven.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying is short.
It's interesting.
I wonder,
I mean he's off thick motherfucker.
There's some guys that even at,
especially as they get
older in their career,
they actually do better
when they go up in weight.
You know?
I wonder if that's going to be the case
where a wonder if he can carry that
power,
that one 70 pounds.
That motherfucker carries
that power so hard.
It does it.
I mean he's got that kind of hit hardware.
It doesn't matter if he
goes up a weight class,
you know it's probably the guys are
going to be able to absorb it better.
But he,
he throws some stupid one punch power
that hauls got a very diverse game too
though.
Hall does a lot of wild shit.
Yeah.
That,
that's a very,
cause you,
when you get the guy that's,
that's very,
very [inaudible],
you know,
sometimes that random shits either going
to work really well or it's going to
get you in some trouble and you're
gonna take a fucking beating.
That's true.
Right.
If you miss and you slept and your back
is turned and did you just going to get
bludgeoned,
especially if you can
catch your legs.
I think that it's interesting.
It's a,
it's an interesting thing
because your eye has a,
uh,
I mean he obviously has a
lot of Moitai skills as well,
but he also has a lot of
traditional like karate style,
taekwondo style techniques.
It's always interesting
when you see those,
the,
the clash of those.
Yeah.
I was actually just talking to a layout
as brother on the way back from the,
from the fight to the hotel and uh,
it's kind of awkward.
He's like,
so who do you think one?
Oh Shit.
Ah,
honestly that fight sucked.
It wasn't the best fight of,
but I enjoyed it.
It was,
I wouldn't say that fight,
so it was just,
well,
I mean for,
I don't know,
I didn't like it very much because I
think that neither of them did enough to,
to really win that much.
I mean,
it was,
it was a toss up.
It was,
it was just not exciting to me.
Maybe you're so crazy.
I thought it was very exciting.
It was just so crazy.
It was just one of the things that,
I mean,
it had,
it had flashes of brilliance.
Both guys are awesome.
I liked both guys a lot.
It's just,
it just was a bad matchup.
It didn't work out well.
Well,
you know what I think,
I think that it wasn't as exciting as
it could have been because not a lot of
action took place.
But to me it was very entertaining because
I was watching a puzzle take place.
That's true.
And I was watching it trying to be solved.
I was watching Phil Davis
tried to hit to take down.
Yeah,
I was watching Liotta try
to defend and land shots.
And Phil Davis landing shots of his own.
You know,
and it's interesting,
you know,
if it was just a kickboxing match it
would be curious to see how it would have
gone down.
But you throw in the
wrestling and you know,
Davis accounted himself
very well on the feet.
Yeah.
Which I think surprised a lot of people.
You know,
you look at the way Machida knocked out.
Ryan Bader,
you look at the way Machida knocked out
Thiago Silva Machida's used that sniping
style on some really highly skilled
strikers and fuck them up bad.
But you know,
they,
especially the Thiago Silva fight,
I mean Ooh.
And Bader man caught him
with one punch coming in.
I mean he's a bad motherfucker
as far as his counters.
And Phil Davis didn't really
take any of them full clip.
You know,
he avoided,
he took some shots but he
rolled with a lot of them.
He had good defense,
took a good shot.
Like it showed good chin constantly.
What?
He never was squared up.
He was constant.
He was constantly moving
back and forth and,
and had good head movement.
But you know,
I think Machida landed more strikes.
Oh yeah.
You know,
so it becomes a matter of what's more
important is to take down more important.
But when he did he hit a take down what,
how much damage was actually
accomplished during a tank down.
Exactly.
Do you feel like there's like a,
an overhaul that needs to be
done with the scoring system?
They definitely need to figure this
out because there's been so many,
I mean,
put my,
my shitty call aside.
I mean,
there's been so many that are bad that,
I mean they need to have a,
um,
maybe it's a scoring system
where a takedown is this much,
you know,
but it,
it just has to be like fought over by a
big group people to just to just figure
out every angle,
you know,
and,
and because people are going to keep
on getting screwed no matter what.
And for folks who don't understand,
again,
we talked about if you're
not like a fan of the sport,
the,
the state athletic
commission is the one who uh,
choose the judges and you know,
the rules are in place essentially
like piggyback from boxing.
Yeah,
they paid,
they took the ten nine system.
So one fighter,
uh,
if they win,
they get 10 points.
If they lose the round,
they get nine points and the
difference is in a boxing match,
there's 10,
nine and then there's 10,
eight.
If there's a knockdown,
it's like,
it's easier to define ten seventh,
there's two knocked down.
It's,
it's pretty easy to define.
It's very rare that fighter gets
knocked down but wins the round.
Whereas in MMA you're dealing with a
longer round and you're dealing with all
these other variables,
kicks and take downs
near submission attempts.
If a guy like peppers,
a guy with a with strikes
and then he gets taken down.
But absolutely nothing happens
while he's on the ground.
He just ties the guy up.
How much damage does he take and is it
equal to all the punches that he landed
before you were taking?
He was taken down.
It becomes a weird situation of like
what's worth more forcing the fight into
the area where the fighter wants it,
whether it's through a takedown or forcing
the fight by standing up and landing
strikes Leister by stopping the tape.
Right.
What is more,
what's worth more?
Is it a,
you know,
a take down or defending yourself and
attacking from the guard and getting a
near submission?
Yeah,
like if a guy takes you down but you
almost get them in a triangle like,
hmm,
how does a judge really know
how to score that correctly?
That's it gets tricky.
Right.
Especially not some random person who
got their job just because they know they
know someone who works there.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sure they
teach them some stuff,
but my take on it has always been there.
So many fans out there that would love
that Gig and they were like huge fans of
MMA and would do a good job.
Much better job.
Yeah.
I think it should be like a Yelp
thing and the Internet Yelp thing.
They should do what you do
without at the UFC from now on,
which do online vote came to give them
an opportunity for an online metro pcs
vote.
Metro pcs.
Let's make this happen.
Maybe a bud light vote,
bud light.
Bud light doesn't like us anymore.
The Culinary Union got rid of him.
Ooh,
I think it's bud light or Miller,
wherever it was.
I don't know.
Um,
Overeem and browns this weekend too,
man.
Um,
I want to Travis to win because I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm friends with them,
but,
okay.
Can he,
I mean Overeem's too cocky,
you know,
mate,
maybe,
you know,
we,
we saw that in,
in the,
in the Silva fight.
He got knocked out.
He's a better fighter technically.
Then I think just about anyone
in the heavyweight division,
if you break down just about each aspect,
but,
okay.
I don't know if it's
his lazy or what it is.
He just,
he casts out.
It's just there's
something wrong with him.
Well,
I think you also asked to
deal with his hormones.
I mean,
yeah,
of course this is a reality of that.
Let,
let's be honest here.
Yeah.
You can't not talk about that exactly.
He had a completely different shape to
his body when he came back after testing
positive for testosterone.
Yeah.
So when,
when you do that,
you know,
I mean,
and I,
you know,
I have no reason to believe that he
didn't accidentally get this injection by
this doctor who was going
to fix your shoulder.
Yeah.
It might have happened that way,
you know,
or it might've been that in pride and
there's other organizations and k one you
could get away with doing things and
then when you get off those things,
the problem is your body doesn't exactly
know what the fucking do exactly.
Because uh,
your,
your testosterone is really low and he,
so he tested like really low for
his last fight against big foot.
Yeah.
Like almost in like a dangerous area.
Like whoa,
that's a professional athlete and this
is like really low and you're that big.
Yeah.
So it's interesting and it's
unfortunate because man,
you juiced up dude up
and he's a motherfucker.
Yeah.
You know when,
when he was finding Brock Lesnar,
and I'm not saying he was juiced up,
but let's just say for instance,
if he was juiced up,
then God damn,
he looked good and scary.
Dude that fight against Brock Lesnar,
he ragdolled Lesnar,
he slammed those kicks into his body
and he was kicking Lesnar and Lesnar was
just like ultra wrestler.
Yeah.
He didn't give a fuck.
You still slamming kicks into objects
and knees and do his midsection.
The clench and Laszlow
couldn't take him down.
You like,
how is this pain hundred pound guys
that were just clubbing each other like,
oh dude,
whatever he was on,
let's say he was on nothing.
Yeah,
whatever that,
that shape that he was in back then,
that's the scary it.
Yes.
That's the Overeem.
Did everybody thought it was going
to be the greatest heavyweight?
You've all time,
just wicked ground game.
So Mitzvah,
Torah,
Belford winds,
the Abu Dhabi trials.
I mean he's,
he's a motherfucker one.
The Europeans,
as you know,
a grappler,
straight grappler.
That's a,
that's a big fucking fight,
man.
You know what else?
A big fine.
Travis.
Uh,
uh,
excuse me.
Matt Brown versus Mike Pyle.
That's another very interesting fight.
A good fight.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go with Mike.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think piles too.
Crafty.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I think it is.
I think that that Brown's good.
I mean he's,
you know,
he's obviously been in
forever for a reason,
but I think that,
uh,
that piles to crafty,
he'll,
he'll end up getting him as something
piles a craft and motherfucker,
he's,
he's an underdog man.
And it's not in this fight necessarily.
I'm sure it probably is listed as an
underdog with Matt Brown coming off his
last fight.
But I meaning that division,
he's like a dark horse.
Like you can be sure.
A lot of the top guys,
you know,
and everybody that trains with Mike Pyle
will you that like Mike Pyle and the
gym is this motherfucker.
Yeah.
Like he's even guys that have beaten him.
He fucking trounces in the gym.
You know,
it's like just sort of coming
into his own final as a fighter.
And he's had a long career already,
but Matt Brown is a
special kind of savage.
Yes.
This is a,
there's a darkness to that man's heart
when he fucking comes after dudes.
You could like,
you could smell the devil in the
room when he's beaten on dudes.
I'm telling you,
man,
that fight with Jordan mean that
that was a fight to the death.
That was a fight to the death match.
And I think if I saw that fight,
that was an incredible fight.
Incredible fucking fight.
He went after me and in me and he's like,
tough,
talented kid.
He's fucking good.
And Matt Brown put a assault on him.
It was a,
you smelled the devil who smelled just
just wisp of brimstone as he's beating
the fuck out of this dude.
You're like this guy.
There's a,
there's a certain fury that that dude
brings into the cage is he's got that
instinct.
He's got that,
that,
that wants to wear your
skin kind of thing.
All these fucking dudes
that went through rehab.
What is it about the Rehab?
Oh yeah,
man.
He had also some similar near
death experiences with drugs.
Rory Macdonald's so weird.
I see it.
Its own issues but you see
what it's got his own issues.
But uh,
it's uh,
think about um,
uh,
court court McGee.
Yeah.
Another one.
Same sort of situation.
That dude's fierce.
Man.
Court McGee is a bad motherfucker
and he doesn't get tired man.
He never gets tired,
keeps calm and have you see
that Gal elevation training.
There you go.
He elevation with weight vests in hills.
The fucking dude runs miles
with a weight vest on.
He doesn't get tired.
He's a tank.
Yeah,
he's a scary dude.
And it's the same thing.
These dudes that go
through crazy adversity,
even if it's self imposed
adversity like drugs.
There's some,
you guys been to the other side?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
So Hannah,
I don't ever want to go back,
but you,
you,
you have had like a near death experience.
I died but then he didn't die right away.
Got My,
that I got hit with like three Epi pens
and the paddles can just see aliens.
Um,
no,
there was no light.
I woke up in the hospital with my
brother just shaking his head at me.
Whoa.
So you didn't know anything
and this was a real overdose.
This wasn't like,
oh,
I overdosed and they've
let me out the night.
That night.
No,
I was in the hospital for a week.
Whoa.
Like I aspirated like I had pneumonia,
like I actually was dead
and they brought me back.
Was it pills?
Yeah,
it was mix of,
of pills and alcohol and more pills and
this other pills and some GHB and some
God damn.
I just,
and I was sober for a while and I just
went right back and I just used me
getting a tattoo as an
excuse to get fucked up.
And it,
uh,
I literally,
I remember,
I remember parts of it and then I remember
waking up in the hospital with just
like,
you know,
one of my friends and I don't
know how the hell she got there.
Still to this day.
I never even asked to just to stop your
story right now and make the rest of it
up and write a book about what
I learned on the other side.
How many dudes get to
go to the other side?
Ah,
just make a dope book about it.
Make some shit up.
I saw the light.
You could do it.
You've been to heaven.
He came back,
man.
You could tell us some shit.
Just makes me,
it's true.
Okay.
Shh.
Don't tell anybody.
Okay,
so you don't want really,
you wanna know what happened.
Do you feel,
um,
like they have like a
second chance at life?
Yeah,
definitely feel like I
have a second chance.
Uh,
and he did it feel like that?
Like tangibly like wow,
I kind of got to get this thing right?
Um,
no,
because I still fucked up after that.
I still,
honestly,
I still dropped the ball
a couple times after that.
I still just,
Oh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm running out of time.
Is it three minutes left?
I,
I'm a,
I'm a constant threat to myself.
Oh,
please get it together.
So you such a fun guy and that's what I'm,
I'm working,
I'm a work in progress.
I love underdog stories.
I love when a dude pulls it out.
Like you fucked it up in the beginning.
You,
Eh,
gets it on track.
I love those stories
spinning and cause I think,
I think they're beneficial for everybody.
Yeah.
I think I'm,
I'm not a perfect person.
I never been a person,
perfect person.
I made a lot of fucking mistakes and
I think in talking about mistakes,
not only do I get like some
jokes and relief out of him,
like other people can,
you could realize like,
oh,
he's sucked at life too.
Yeah.
You know?
Anyway,
it's therapy.
It's therapy for me to be able to,
to,
to explain my story to you.
Taking it to a whole new level
is what I'm trying to say.
It's like,
my stories are fucking
ridiculous compared to yours.
I mean,
you fucking die,
dude.
All right.
That's about as fucked up as you can get.
You fucked up so bad.
Your body said we fucking quit and then
science came along and shock this dummy
back to life.
We need them around.
Well look man,
look at that.
You you die and then you come back
and have some awesome fights and back.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
dude,
let's do this again.
Let's do it.
Let's do it more often.
I live close to that for all I that here,
close enough,
a faster car that's just got to deal
with it and this is why you need a
helicopter bitch.
Maseratis not fascinate.
Listen,
congratulations on all your
progress and thank you very much.
It's been a lot of fun and
you can follow him on Twitter.
It's uncle creepy MMA on Twitter and a
uncle creepy MMA on Instagram as well.
I tagged it in a picture I
took of us earlier today.
Ah,
thanks man.
So have fun.
It was fun.
Thank you.
Thanks everybody.
Thanks to our sponsor is
stamps.com legal zoom on.
It's,
uh,
yeah.
You know the fucking deal.
Folks don't have to tell you.
I'll go to the beginning of the podcast.
You want to know the codes,
see a bitches.
Uh,
we'll be back next week with,
uh,
all sorts of goodies.
A much love to you all.
And,
uh,
I'll see you guys in Boston this weekend.
Ooh.